e
morning everyone the time being 10 N9
we'll get
started and today we have um a bunch of
um
presentations um we're probably go
roughly from 9:00 to 3: today with a
lunch break in between and uh similar
probably for tomorrow as
well and those of you on the on the Ways
and Means Committee are not uh familiar
with what's happening we've got um well
you know what we're doing today but we
also have the house many members of the
house finance committee here today
welcome and uh we have representatives
from uh state agencies as well um who
will be doing presentations and others
listening in so uh without further Ado
uh we'll get started with our first um
uh speaker uh Michael Caine from the
office
okay good morning Mr chair members of
the committee for the record we almost
lost Senator grether uh for the record
my name is Michael Kain I'm the
legislative budget assistant uh just
kind of a quick overview for the new
members we are a nonpartisan office with
both an audit and a budget division uh
from your perspective for the committee
we service the ways and means committees
Public Works and capital budget as well
as the finance committees uh so you'll
be the Ways and Means Committee in the
house be working a lot with Chris Shay
the deputy LBA uh when you get into your
Revenue estimates in the next couple of
weeks uh so Chris will be assisting you
just kind of what the LBA does to assist
the way Means Committee Chris will be
assisting you with coordinating with the
agencies with uh keeping uh all your
discussions your figures that you talk
about um in a one sheet a worksheet we
do an agency worksheet that will show
you the the various estimates throughout
the process so you can keep track um
we'll also help with Gen 4 who's who's
your assistant for the committee who's
great who's been here uh for a while um
so Chris will assist you when you put
those worksheets together to come up
with your estimates where you will then
present an a house resolution to the
full house uh timing of that is always
depending upon dependent upon
discussions with leadership uh Etc but
we are pretty early in the process right
now as you know uh the governor governor
aot is working on presenting her budget
the deadline the statutory deadline is
February 15th so the agencies are
working on both the revenue and the
budget side uh with the governor right
now um typically when the governor is uh
developing their budget agencies are
hesitant to really get on record yet uh
to the house ways Means Committee on
where they think re news will be they'll
share all the relevant information but
they're still working with the governor
right now to kind of fine-tune those
estimates and then you can really start
to dig into where they are uh
commissioner stepp is coming in after us
so she can explain to you kind of what
she's doing with the governor right now
um not in detail but just the general
time that it takes those agencies and
committee so to move on to there's a one
pager in your
handout and it's called the fiscal year
25 uh budget status it is
um a point in time document what we see
uh 25 based on the information we
currently
know one thing to know is this has
already changed from the time this was
printed uh it's going to continue to
change as you have your meetings um the
the Acer the annual comprehensive
financial report for 24 which
um provides the balances coming forward
into 25 for the general education trust
fund has been delayed until the end of
January it's my understanding there'll
be another extension our request at the
Fisco committee at the January 30th
meeting uh I'm not sure how long that
extension will be for so until 24 is
finalized uh the balance going into 25
isn't really known it should change
between right now um what the Auditors
are seeing it could change anywhere
between 10 to 15 million between the
general and education trust fund so
these numbers are very fluid um to kind
of go over the budget real quickly and I
I I will make sure I leave enough time
for commissioner step because she's
going to give a great presentation uh
for the budget it was assumed that 25
for the general fund would begin with a
$42 million beginning balance from 24
and the education trust fund would have
a balance of 183 .9 million uh based on
the preliminary cfer figures general
fund was actually 79.7 million so almost
37 million over where the budget writers
had assumed back in June of
23 education trust fund instead of 183.0
came down to about
158.3 uh million so a lower balance uh
two components to that the reason for
the lower education trust fund balance
is um spending the actual adequacy
numbers were higher than budgeted um
based on uh the new law that the
legislature had passed and and the
update on the student counts that were
finalized but also the revenue the um
commissioner stepp will talk about this
as well but the business taxes have not
been performing um as they were
anticipated it's taking a larger hit on
the education trust fund based on those
splits than it is on the general fund so
that's even continuing into 25 when we
look that was true for 24 it's went into
25 where even though the state was down
about 40 something million of uh through
December on revenues the general fund
was up 11 overall because they do have
other Revenue sources such as other
funds um in in a couple of other uh
sources to bail them out whereas the
education trust fund was down almost $50
million in Revenue so although the state
was down the general fund was doing okay
so and you can see that on the estimated
Revenue
when you look at the estimated revenues
on line six carries forward for both the
the budget assumptions and uh the
current status the year-to-date variance
is what's going to change uh throughout
the year uh a general fund up 12.6
million for revenues uh and the
education trust fund down 53.8 million
one of the largest
um kind of buffers for lack of a better
term that the general fund has is the
interest it's earning on funds and
Treasurer mespelli will uh share that
with the committee but the state has
significant interest Revenue because of
the availability of arpa funds almost
two billion of arital funds you have 292
M plus million doll in the rainy day
fund you have positive balances in your
general education trust fund so the the
other interest revenue is significant um
moving forward into 26 and 27 as those
dollars for arer being spent down those
numbers will come down and that's
something on as a Means Committee you're
going to be looking at um going
forward net budget Appropriations uh
again line 11 the budget writers
including laps had assumed about 1.9
million in general funds 1.2 million
education trust funds um there are
unbudgeted Appropriations that aren't
anticipated to the general fund about
$26.4 million in the education trust
fund about 24.8 million um these are um
statutory Appropriations things like
settlements uh true up to the adequacy
calculations um that the state is
obligated to pay by Statute so between
those two on on line 12 is almost $50
million over $50 million of off-budget
Appropriations that are going to hit 25
that weren't
anticipated and then legislative
specials legislative specials are bills
that the legislature actually passes
with Appropriations uh there were um
Appropriations passed in 24 due to the
revenue higher than anticip ipated but
also um in 25 there were some
Appropriations pushed uh off to 25 $
45.1 million uh in the general fund and
$3.7 million in the education trust fund
so if we were to end uh on Friday
because I know it has changed the
general fund estimated balance at the
end of 25 knowing what we know today was
about 8 uh million and that's for 25 for
the education trust fund um it was $15
million
positive balance when compared to the
budget figures of June of 2023 that's a
budget variance in the general fund of a
negative 21.2 million and the education
trust fund of over 100 million about
107.3 million um that education trust
fund balance of 125 most likely will
come down by another 10 due to uh court
ordered placements and some other um
auditing activities that are happening
now to properly charge it to the the
fund so you're probably looking closer
to the 115 range at the education trust
fund um and then if you look at your
general fund we know that the judicial
council is going to come into the fiscal
committee to ask for additional General
funds of about $3 million so that 18
will be close to 21 by the end of the
month um and there's a few agencies that
can come in to ask fiscal committee for
additional general fund Appropriations
um Justice had already come in uh for
several million dollars for litigation
uh judicial council is the next one and
then Corrections will keep an eye on um
and then your Revenue performance you'll
be monitoring as a way Means Committee
you'll be monitoring your Revenue
performance for January and February and
March you a portion of March as they
come in and so that's going to change
the lapse amount agencies miss their
laps amount that's their unexpended
Appropriations that are assumed by the
um the finance committees they missed it
by about $20 million in 24 uh that was
the first time the agency laps has
estimate has been missed in several
years um it is the first year of a bium
25 is assuming another
117.5 million of laps funds um from the
general fund we know that the
commissioner of administrative Services
has to put a report together and is
working with current governor right now
to see how 25 will end the preliminary
report shows a lap shortfall of $80
million um those are and I'll just
caution everyone that's very very early
um there are a lot of non-aps and funds
into the second year of the banum uh HHS
has significant non-aps funds into 25
that will lapse at the end of the bium
so I'd be very surprised to see an $80
million lap shortfall that the budget
writers will have to take care of uh but
it is something to watch so there's a
lot of numbers uh that are moving um and
that's kind of where we stand now we'll
be working with with the ways Means
Committee but also with the finance
committee um as we finalize this and I
can update this sheet once we have the
final numbers for your January and your
February just so the committee knows um
we also use a warrant report from
administrative services to see what the
off-budget Appropriations are um so I
hope this is helpful right now it is
kind of showing a trend down so we know
going into the 26 and 27 uh budget
session your revenues most likely aren't
going to be as um robust as they were
the last few years where the state has
really benefited from higher than
anticipated revenues I think on a
budgeting side the governor sununu in
his agency budget request had already
requested reductions in agency budgets
of close to 4% and I know the governor
is currently working with the agencies
for further reductions just to be ready
for uh when they finalize their revenue
estimates so it'll be a little different
budget process than it has been in the
last few years
um so that's something that we can we'll
update you as we go through so I can
stop there and answer any questions from
the thank you um so this sheet you've
given us is as of uh January 7th yes
Elberta thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um can you please
describe exactly what unbudgeted
sure so for unbudgeted
Appropriations um attorney general
litigation for the general fund attorney
general litigation expense of about $6.7
million um you do have a legislative
historical fund it's about
25,000 uh legal settlements so the AG
the Attorney General can enter into
legal settlements um so about almost $12
million in legal settlements so far in
25 and then if we look at a couple of
the other big ones abandoned property
claims so if the state has abandoned
property uh they do need to pay that
back when the uh the owners do come to
reclaim that so that is a hit on the
general fund you'll also be seeing the
ised uh abandoned property uh Revenue in
other funds when your committee starts
to go through estimating revenues but
the actual cost uh comes against the
general fund um another $100,000 for
Border claims death benefits um and then
uh there was a a reallocation of
certified Corrections Officers which was
a um a house bill to or trailer Bill
provision put in so that's the about the
$26 million um on the education trust
fund side that's the 24 million about 20
million of
that 20 million of that is estimated
adequacy payments over what the budget
had assumed to years ago based on actual
student counts based on actual property
tax per pupil and and the various other
components so that was over budget
another $34 million in education Freedom
accounts based on actual usage uh so
those are immediate draws off the
education trust
fund okay
thanks any other questions yes thank you
quick answer is the Liquor Commission
and question sure sure the question was
why is the the current eer uh delayed so
significantly and the biggest reason is
the Liquor Commission made a change to
their point of service system um from
one system to another system before the
end of close of the fiscal year
uh hundreds of millions of dollars going
back and forth between two systems you
really have to reconcile the two systems
down to the dollar it was uh what I
understand seamless from the consumer
but in the back room for the accountants
it's a it's it was quite the work so
there was a several week delay um in
them getting the them being liquor
getting the information back to uh our
Auditors so we could begin auditing uh I
can tell you that lior did have some
staffing issues with two uh significant
Employees leaving uh that that only
added to the the the heavy T the big
task that they had um but they've also
done a good job in hiring additional
assistance from Barry dun mcneel uh to
help to close that so um that is the
biggest that's that's a large issue that
has to be resolved prior to the state
finalizing um the act for for 24 sure
follow
[Music]
I uh so the governor does have the
opportunity to come to the fiscal
committee to request budget reductions
and and and um
I right now in January I do not
anticipate that happening I anticipate
any of those reductions or lapsing of
funds to happen in the budget process um
I could you could see things and i'
leave it up to the governor things like
freezes hiring freezers or equipment
freezers uh the the typical but no
direct cuts to agencies for 25 yet um I
know Governor A's probably talking with
individual agencies to see to get their
lapse number exactly right just to see
where we can end up because that is $18
million or 20 million on the general
fund um that could be made up from a
lapse as you know um so I do not anticip
I could be wrong it could be happening
as we speak but I don't anticipate it
this far in the year because it takes a
little bit for those cuts to happen um
even within a hiring freeze you're not
going to see any cuts for several months
and in a reductions for several months
thanks represent
Alman thank you
on does the Liquor Commission
problems um mean that the numbers we've
changeable I mean there's always a
possibility representative that the
Liquor Commission um what's going on in
the audit right now to determine uh the
final net profit of the Liquor
Commission could have an impact uh we
haven't heard anything from the
executive side that that's an issue
hopefully this is a look back issue from
the audit perspective just to make sure
that the
24 um is closed out properly and has the
proper net profit but going forward I
would they've had a they began the
fiscal year with the new point of
service so I don't anticipate seeing any
um big issues with what they're
reporting right now uh what you're going
to see in liquor most of the variants is
going to be what does um as you know
additional funds necessary for the um
Medicaid expansion for the granite
care does come if there's additional
need that comes from the liquor fund so
you're going to see liquor missing their
revenue if you look in the revenue Focus
part of that and they'll they'll explain
to you during ways means part of that a
lot of that has to do with the cost of
the Medicaid um expansion what has to be
drawn down from the liquor fund which is
out of control of out of the control of
anybody
you that was perfect timing now we'll
good morning Mr chair member of the
House and Senate Ways and Means
Committee Lindsay step I'm the
commissioner at the Department of
Revenue Administration happy to be here
with you this morning for the next hour
and a half or so um so everyone should
have in front of them a presentation
okay so flipping to page two just to
give you an overview of the Department
of Revenue Administration we administer
14 taxes for the state and that
represents
76.7% or a little over $2.5 billion
dollar of Revenue collected for the
general and education trust funds in
fiscal year
2024 we have important insights into the
performance of the state's most
significant rever new sources which I'll
talk about a bit today but we do lack
the capacity to perform more complex
economic predi predictions but you have
two full days of speakers or a day and a
half of speakers behind us who are very
well versed in their areas so you'll get
plenty of
information um the presentation outlined
today will talk about what revenues look
like year-to date we'll talk about
factors that affect the revenues and
then we'll look at how revenues are
trending compared to
plan my goal today is to give you kind
of a basic understanding of how the tax
types work so that you have a frame of
reference for the information that
you're going to hear over the next day
and a half I believe we'll be coming
back to the Committees to do a bit of a
deeper dive into exactly how the
revenues work and provide you with some
more information I didn't want to
overwhelm you too too much of today but
again wanted to make sure you have a
general understanding of the taxes so
that you can process the information
that you're going to hear for example
when you hear from um commissioner
Caswell um later on today and you talk
about travel and tourism you'll be able
to understand or think about how those
travel and tourism Trends or things
happening in the market could affect the
meals and rentals tax so that's kind of
my goal for this morning um I am going
to go tax by tax and Mr chair if it's
okay with you I'll pause at after each
tax for questions yes I think that's a
good idea okay represent Aly did you
have yes I just want to take issue with
lacks the capacity to perform more
complex economic problems what you can
do today is is c a century past what we
had in uh 10 years ago sure yeah we do
have a lot of data and we do um a fair
amount of work to analyze um based on
the DAT that we have but most of the
data that comes in comes in on tax forms
and so um there is other parts to the
bigger picture related to taxes more
than just what comes in on the form but
we do do our best to analyze the data
that's presented to
us okay moving on to page three we'll
start talking about the meals and
rentals tax so the meals and rentals tax
is levied on consumers on the purchase
of tax ible meals accommodation rentals
and motor vehicle rentals uh the tax
rate was historically at 9% through
September 30th of 2021 and was reduced
to 85% on October 1st of 2021 the taxes
collected by the operator and remitted
to the Dr monthly so you go out to
dinner the tax is collected by the
restaurant um at the time that you pay
your bill and then at the end of each
month that operator takes all the taxes
that they've collected and remits it to
the
State there are two um transfers that
come out of the meals and rentals tax
the first is the school building Aid
Debt Service um that has been in place
for a number of years um and it started
at $ 14.6 million in fiscal year 2012
and has been gradually decreasing to 6.8
million in fiscal year 24 and is
currently at 6.6 million for this year
there is also a municipal Revenue fund
transfer where treasury distributes 30%
of net meals and rooms income from the
most recently completed fiscal year
that's distributed to cities and towns
um and then that Revenue comes out of
the monthly um collections each month in
fiscal year 25 we'll be sending $1
136.6 million to cities and towns
through the municipal Revenue fund
transfer looking at how M&R has
performed over the past few years
um we saw a
21.7% increase from 21 to 22 an 8.4
increase from 22 to 23 and a 3.9%
increase from 23 to
24 for fiscal year 25 to date we've seen
a 3.8% increase over the prior year so
you'll see that the growth in M&R has
slowed a bit um I believe a good portion
of that growth in 21 to 22 that was
coming off of the co 19 pandemic um I
think a lot of us realized how much we
liked traveling and liked going out to
eat um and so there was some pent up
demand that occurred so we saw some
pretty significant growth coming out of
the pandemic the tax is still growing
but the growth has
slowed um factors that we look to um and
that you'll hear about over the next day
and a half um that can impact M&R uh low
unemployment rates right when you're
when we have good solid um employment
that does allow consumer to go out to
dinner to travel so those low
unemployment rates are good for for M&R
Revenue um the impact of inflation on
fuel prices and food costs so talk about
fuel prices for a second that could put
a little bit of a damper on minr if
that's causing folks to not travel by
car as much um but on the other hand
with increase in food C costs if that
then increases prices at restaurants
then that increased price could increase
the meals and rentals tax because the
tax is a function of what you pay at the
restaurant so inflation can kind of go
both ways um in terms of impact on
M&R similar to the unemployment rate
strong wages when wages are good and
there's more disposable income um
consumers are more likely to spend and
that's positive for the meals and
rentals tax um and then the weather uh
being in a state that has four beautiful
seasons and many of us um and many
others like to travel here to enjoy them
when the weather is good and that
includes Sunny Summers and cold snowy
Winters um and everything in between um
that tends to increase tourism and
increase um the meals and rentals
tax on the next slide on page four
you'll see um historic performance of
the meals and rentals
tax from 2015 to
2024 um you will see from
21 to 22 there was a bit of a decline
that is when the municipal Revenue
transfer has started to come out of the
meals and rentals tax so there is
underlying growth there but the revenue
to the general fund and the education
trust fund did dip there due to that
Revenue being siphoned off into the
municipal Revenue fund um but generally
you know leading into the pandemic
pretty um consistent year-over-year
growth in the tax we did see a decrease
in the tax um with the impact of the
restrictions related to the p pmic um
but as I mentioned on the previous slide
we have recovered um quite nicely from
that on page
five you'll see a breakdown of the
portion of the revenue that is
attributable to meals that is
attributable to rentals so those would
be hotel accommodations short-term
rentals that sort of thing and then
motor vehicle
rentals so looking at fiscal year
2024 just under 80% of meals and rentals
tax revenue came in from
meals
18.8% from um hotel accommodations and
other rentals of sleeping accommodations
and then just about 2% in motor vehicle
rentals this is pretty consistent um
year-over gear although starting in
fiscal year 22 we've kind of seen um a
shift to uh rentals um and a a little
bit more away from meals um but again
just strong good performance um from the
meals and rentals tax that's the last
slide I have on that so I'll pause for
questions thank you
Senator
comp sure so the question was any sense
of the compliance on Airbnb for M&R um I
can't talk about individual taxpayers
but I can talk about that sort of of um
online tourism industry where you rent
accommodations and there's Airbnb and
there's a number of other ones um those
entities are are licensed um as a single
license so if you do operate on one of
those online travel platforms um that
platform will collect and remit the tax
on your behalf so if you um say have a
ski condo um up in Lincoln and you rent
that through Airbnb you don't need a
separate meals and rentals license they
will handle as long as you only rent
through one of the platforms they will
handle that compliance for you um if you
happen to also rent off of the platforms
you would need to have a second license
but I do believe um it makes it a lot
easier for folks that are utilizing um
short-term rentals um or renting out
property on a short-term basis
compliance is a lot easier given the
online platforms so so I do think
there's been increased compliance as a
result of
that represent El
me yes could you say something briefly
about uh there are a large um number of
people who are renting their back room
to somebody to raise money and uh it
seems to be a surprise for them to
discover that when you discover them how
do you go about looking looking for that
market so um depending on how they're
renting so if they're not renting on one
of the platforms um it can be harder to
sort of find those rentals and if
they're renting them on a short-term
basis so essentially less than six
months um that would qualify as a rental
under the meals and rentals tax um under
statute they're technically supposed to
obviously have a meals and rentals
license and be posting that license
number when they are putting their
accommodation out for rent um and so if
we do come across postings where we're
not seeing a meals and rentals license
we would follow up with that individual
um also this is the type of situation
where other people that are renting and
paying the tax um tend to keep an eye on
their friends and neighbors who are not
and so we will um receive referrals
sometimes um we have an option on our
website to send us an anonymous um um
recommendation of a location that we
should look into and so that's sometimes
how we get information as
well thank you
that uh solves the mystery I had of an
extremely irritated constituent who was
only putting things up on the billboard
in Dartmouth
Hitchcock representative ORS thank you
Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question so what what do you believe the
impact on the uh tax revenue for fuel
and inflation is right now I mean is it
significant the
material
so I think what we've talked about
previously is um obviously if fuel
prices you know the gas pump prices get
too high that will cause people to maybe
slow their travel right they might not
um take those day trips or those long
weekend trips that you know um we see a
number of cars I drive up 93 every day
um and Friday afternoons leaving
conquered going north there's a lot of
traffic um so if fuel prices get to a
point that people decide not to take
those weekend trips I think that would
have a negative impact on M&R I don't
think we're seeing that at this point I
think fuel prices are relatively stable
at the moment um in terms of whether um
inflation causes you know input costs
food cost to
increase it would and then prices
essentially increase and so the base
that the tax rate is applied to
increases that would increase Revenue to
the point where the prices get so high
that consumers start to demand less
right um and so there is that Tipping
Point where the prices get too high and
you know you're used to going out every
Thursday night to your local restaurant
for a burger and that burger suddenly
gets above $15 you might be like well
maybe we'll go every other Thursday and
that's the point where we would see
those prices impact um the M&R tax
negatively because the demand would be
less so it's kind of a balancing act
follow up follow up so from what I'm
seeing uh some call it the Trump effect
but gas prices where I purchase my gas
have steadily been coming down and uh so
I anticipate that's going to continue
and uh just for future reference and for
everybody that's listening there is no
bad weather in New Hampshire it's poor
choices of clothing there you go thank
you yes represent opal uh commissioner
thank you for taking my question um as a
first termer and I apologize to veterans
in the room um the school building Aid
Debt Service reduction is that a
function of demand or legislation
strictly a function of legislation as
the um bonds are paid off the principle
and interest decreases so the amount
that we need to transfer each month is
question yes uh
Senator me fers the number of filers
changed significantly in the last years
that's a great question um I would say
we have seen a slight increase in the
number of filers um but not really
substantially because for every
restaurant that might close and new one
might open um I think absent the online
travel platforms if all of those folks
needed to be licensed and couldn't
operate under the license of the online
travel platform we would see a
significant increase um so I think
there's definitely more um tax that's
being collected but I might not
necessarily see it in the number of
operators follow up so we talk about the
Vero have a lot more units
exactly okay anything else seeing none
we'll move on to real estate transfer
tax real estate transfer tax also known
as the Rett so the r is a tax on the
transfer sale or granting of real
property the rate is um
a150 but that's going to be split 75
cents is the obligation of the purchaser
and 75 cents is the obligation of the
seller
so R Revenue in recent years um peaked
in fiscal year 2022 so from fiscal year
2021 to 2022 we saw a 10.9% increase in
Revenue um and then revenues have been
decreasing so from 22 to 23 we saw an
11.6% decrease from 23 to 24 we saw a
10.6% decrease um although we might be
seeing a little bit of a bright light
starting with real estate transfer tax
in fiscal year 2025 for the first 6
months we are 6.8% below plan but we're
6.1% ahead of last year the important
thing to know about the real estate
transfer tax is you again it's a bit of
a balancing act you need the
transactions to
occur and you also need the price for
the tax to come in so we can see and as
we have been seeing lower transactions
but at higher prices can still generate
significant Revenue uh alternatively
more transactions at lower prices can
still generate good Revenue um for the
most part over the past couple years and
we'll talk about this on the next slide
too um prices of the transactions are
high right home prices are at all-time
Highs but the inventory and the
transaction volume is very low um so I
think what we're seeing in these first
six months of fiscal year 25 compared to
last year is we are seeing some pickup
in the number of
transactions so factors that affect the
r Revenue interest rates obviously when
interest rates are high there's a
decreased demand people can't afford to
necessarily um move or purchase a home
um inflation affecting household budgets
right so it's all we're all working off
of a pot of Revenue and inflation cause
causes other prices to increase that
might put a strain on some household
budgets the available inventory like I
said I think that is some of what we're
seeing in that we are seeing a little
bit more inventory out there so more
transactions are able to occur and then
property values which would in um
increase the prices so we saw in New
Hampshire a total equalized value for
all property in New Hampshire in 2022 of
300 almost 312 billion and that went up
to
3375 billion in fiscal year 23 so
ing on page
seven we'll just talk a little bit about
how November of this year compared to
November of last year we did see a
slight decline in the listings um
November December can be a bit of a slow
time um for Real Estate um but we did
see pending sales increase um by 15.4%
over the prior year and the median sale
price increased by
11.1% so there again you have the
transactions increasing and the prices
increasing and so that's um largely
driving the increase that we've seen
compared to the prior
year um for November
2024 um a single family home had an
affordability index of 73 which is an
increase of 9% over the prior year so
what's an affordability index
um it basically measures whether a
typical family earns income to qualify
for a mortgage loan on a typical home so
take average family average home what
would it take to get a mortgage and then
how does the essentially the income
compare to what they would need and so
as an example if you had an index of 120
that would mean that the median
household income was
120% so more than enough to qualify for
what you would need for an average home
when we're looking at a affordability
index of
73% the median income is is not enough
it's only 73% of what would be needed to
purchase a
home this um this affordability index
was at 100 right around December of
2021 but since the prices have increased
and since recently interest rates have
gone up that amount has dropped so
that's just kind of an index that we
watch to just see how easy and likely it
would be for folks to be able to um
purchase their first home um and enter
the real estate
market um and then lastly for November
of 2024 single family home sales
increase 3 and a half% compared to last
year so again we're seeing those
transactions start to pick up um and
that's helpful to drive the real estate
transfer
tax going to page eight this is the
10-year
Trend you'll see um 2015 to 2020 pretty
steady year-over-year
growth 2021 2022 right the demand
skyrocketed and prices started to
increase and then now in from fiscal
22 through fiscal year 24 we started to
see that decline as you know again that
the inventory isn't really there
transactions are not happening and the
prices are really high and might be um
you know pricing some people out of the
market I will say though if you kind of
took your pen and you know ignored what
happened in 21 and 22 and you look to
where we are in 24 we're kind of on that
General trajectory that we've been
seeing so if you kind of take out the
anomalies of what we saw in that postco
time the real estate transfer tax is
performing well um and we are increasing
again from fiscal year 24 to 25
so we just had a bit of a anomalous bump
there for a little
bit okay great uh represent El me yes we
have another problem though that's in
your department which is property
assessment and and we've got laws
binding that which make it difficult to
change but um a lot of municipalities
are realizing that their way
undervalued because of this because we
we use recent sales and the recent sales
have been
astronomical and that leaves all of the
$250
$150,000 house
owners
uh in in much more trouble when we
reassess and I've been hearing a lot uh
from different individuals around my
area uh with great fear about the
reassessments and I don't know what we
can it I don't think there's any way
that we can uh smooth the
process so um under state law
municipalities are required to reassess
property every five years um that is the
the minimum interval some municipalities
wait and do it every five years um in
which case when you take a pre um covid
assessment and then you look to doing an
assessment in the last year or two there
will be significant increases in the
value of the property um because of what
the real estate market has done in the
past couple of years some municipalities
are more proactive and they do those
reassessments before the fiveyear mark
in order to do exactly what you said
representative to smooth out the
increase um the increase in an
individual properties assess investment
again isn't necessarily a bad thing um
that is certainly the value of your
property increasing is a good thing when
it comes time to potentially sell it's a
good thing when you want to refinance or
take out a home equity loan um it's a
good asset to have um where it can be a
bit of a surprise for folks is when that
increase happens on their tax bill um
and the increase in their property is
more than the average increase in the
town so if your property value increased
20% in a reassessment year and everyone
else's property the average increase was
20% and the spend in your town was
consistent from one year to the next
there will be no change in your tax
bill where you see the changes in the
tax bill is if your property increases
disproportionately to the other um
properties in your community and or if
there a significant change to the
spending in your municipality but just
because you see an increased assessment
does not necessarily mean you're going
to see an increase in your tax bill and
many municipalities when they go through
a full reassessment they actually see
their tax rate drop their per thousand
tax rate drop and that's exactly because
the increase in the assessment does not
necessarily mean a higher tax bill that
higher tax bill is going to come when
the increase is disproportionate and or
the municipality decides to spend more
money
followup yes but the problem is that
it's extremely difficult to explain that
to most of the citizens I
understand um the the Dr we do have we
put out um some education a couple years
ago relative to this exact how the
assessments and tax bills kind of
function um I recently spoke with a
repor at the union leader who is looking
into it and again trying to provide
education and certainly if you ever have
constituents that come to you with
concerns you can come to me and um we
can also talk to our um Municipal and
property division at the Department of
Revenue to help folks understand we get
questions all the time um it is it is uh
a difficult thing for sure to
understand representative Spar followed
by
representative um thank you uh is the uh
Revenue that's collected 100% of it goes
to the general and to the education
funds Does anything go back to the
municipalities so with the real estate
transfer tax um there is nothing that
goes back to the municipalities um the
the tax where the money goes back to the
municipalities is going to be from the
meals and rentals tax follow up follow
up uh do the municipalities have any
Authority uh legal authority to charge a
transfer tax or is that invested with
the state they have to go to the state
for a permission that's at the state
level okay but they can get permission
or they can get a um I don't believe
there's any way for uh the
municipalities to charge a a transfer
tax that happens at the state level okay
thank you yes representative shamberg
thank you Mr chairman thank you
commissioner for taking maybe a two-part
question does the
Dr have a process of checking the
assessments that the towns are supposed
to do is it on
a and what happens if a town does not do
it within the five years great question
yes we not only monitor that the
municipalities are doing the
reevaluations reassessments every five
years but we also then monitor how they
were done and that they were done
according to the standards that the
state has set so it's kind of two-part
we make sure you do it and we make sure
you do it properly if a municipality
does not perform the assessment uh
reassessment at the scheduled time frame
um we um have a way of going to the
board in tax and land appeals and having
that reassessment ordered so that would
happen if it was not done on time and or
if it was not if a reassessment was not
done to the standards that the state has
set we would petition the board attacks
and land appeals and that would go
through the process um with the
reassessment uh representative
M yeah thank you Mr chairman uh my
question is is on commercial property
rela to residential property could you
comment on what you see happening on
valuations of commercial versus
residential and do you see any disparity
in the tax rates between those two sure
so um to answer the second question
first the tax rate that's going to be
set by the municipality is going to be
the tax rate for all property so there's
not going to be a separate commercial or
residential rate um but I will say at a
high level I think what we've seen um
again in the recent years is that the
the value of residential property has
increased more than the value of
commercial property um part of that is
due to you know if you take a
municipality that has a fair amount of
office space commercial office space a
lot of companies aren't using their
office space anymore right employers are
working remote employees are working
remotely they don't need that office
space it's gone vacant and so higher
vacancy rates in commercial property is
going to lower um the value so I would
say we've kind of seen a shift where
maybe commercial property has decreased
a bit and the increas is in residential
property and even at the residential
level you're seeing um we're seeing a
greater increase in um the values of um
like mobile homes and smaller starter
homes um that's where I think we're
seeing the biggest increase in the
residential Market um because you know
the as the prices increase and we talked
about that affordability Index right
where we're not it's not affordable for
a lot of families so that you know
single family home that you were
planning on
purchasing say 10 years ago might not be
the single family home that you can
afford today and so that first home
buyer might be now may be looking
towards a mobile home where you know a
few years ago they were looking at a
small ranch for instance so I think
those are some of the shifts that we're
seeing thank you Mr chairman um could
you characterize the uh relative
disparities between the increases in
commercial property versus residentials
one uh Senator
Rosenwald
follow represent
equ excuse me for a second we had a
little power blip and your your light
went out so thank you um that's a great
question so the total equalized value on
page six is all property commercial
residential all of it um and so yes that
takes into account everything and so
when we talk about um equalized value to
it that's a bit of a Nuance term that
maybe not everyone is familiar with the
the goal of producing that total
equalized value is to bring all property
in the state to Market rates to address
if they haven't if a municipality hasn't
done a reassessment in five years and
their property and their municipality is
very undervalued we take that and bring
it up so the total equalized value
is meant to be the current value of all
property in the state regardless of when
a municipality has done a
reassessment
follow sure we can definitely look at
and bring to the Committees when we do
our deeper dive um the value how the
value of residential versus commercial
has changed in the past few years okay
construction that's not necessarily
something that we get on our tax forms
so um we would necessarily know if a
transfer was a new construction or an
existing home sale but you may hear more
about that from one of the speakers
behind me um and if not we can certainly
try to find some information on that
again wouldn't be data that we would
necessarily have but that's probably out
there somewhere and we can look into
that yes
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question you
said btla can order a reval if Town
hasn't done it what if there are no
assessors that are coming to the North
Country to do that understood um that it
the the assessing
um world or uh profession is um facing
some challenges um that we are very well
aware of um I sit on the assessing
certification board um
and that is something that when these
predicaments face the individual
municipalities we are trying to be
proactive and have conversations with
them long before we get to a point of um
needing to to order a reassessment and
also figuring out ways that we can be of
assistance so the Dr has assisted some
municipalities in some work that's
needed to be done um but this is this is
something that that the state is going
to have to to tackle um because you're
right there is a lack of of assessors in
the North Country
followup yes followup okay are you aware
that there is one town right now in the
North country that's under a court order
to have a uh reval done this year since
they had an extension from 23 to 24 and
from 24 to
aware um is let me just okay let me just
just asked do we have a link on the
website that describe on the gr website
done so the assessing so short answer is
yes um assessing the Dr monitors that
the assess the reassessments are done
and how they're performed the standards
for
setting
um the of how the assessments should be
performed are done through the assess
Standards Board and that is a board
that's administratively attached to the
Department of Revenue um and so those
are the folks that kind of set the
standards and then we monitor that
they're being followed so the short
answer is yes you can get there on our
website and we can certainly provide um
a link for folks to to get to where they
need to go right it may be a plus if
constituents are asking sure so yes
Senator G um I sit on the assessing
Standards Board the assessing Standards
Board in their last meeting being left
Friday
Friday that established a committee to
do just exactly what your is trying to
find a way to solve the the problem
certainly bety Pat Patton was elected
the chair of that and if anyone is
interested in joining that committee I
that Senator
Aly
yes I've been having a conversation with
my assessor who was an assessor also for
some places in the east of the state as
well as Lebanon and
and he from what I understood at any
rate he was saying that well they have
for looking at retail and Commercial
properties which includes a huge number
of residential towers that have gone up
in Lebanon in the last few years um
they have been
on
the he is saying that it is no longer
economical to build
condominium
properties because all of the costs of
doing that are in the
price whereas and you can can sell it
and get the money
immediately uh but it doesn't any longer
make up for that that and and the the
apartment towers that are rental only um
are considerably cheaper to build and
particularly when it comes to looking at
things like the real estate transfer tax
or looking at the property taxes going
forward because there are a number of
the elements in the process of building
one of those that do not not
get considered in the value of the
sales yes represent BL um so I want to
get
back
correct correct
good point yes so the real estate
transfer tax is going to be collected um
when the deed is filed at the county and
then the counties remit that to the
state every month and they keep a
portion of that Revenue as a commission
so you don't we're not receiving um the
real estate transfer tax from any every
individual as part of those transactions
it's recorded at the county level and
passed to the state at that point follow
so thank you for that so yeah go back to
transaction amounts again I think we
kind of have a onew punch going on right
now between High inflation enough
interest rates housing pric are higher
interest
rates
down right but indications look like
again my last looking at the
realtor.com U handouts hous prices are
starting to drop and we are seeing
indication from the F that interest
rates are going to start to drop which
should hopefully bod well for some
upcoming take a little bit to get there
but we should see
some that be ass you have as well I I
would agree um I'm me just flipping here
to some data that I have so the real
estate transfer tax um as I mentioned
earlier doesn't come in you know really
uniformly across the year right we have
good real estate seasons and slower real
estate Seasons November December January
February that can be a slower time for
transaction
transactions tend to pick up in the
spring and summer especially late summer
as families are trying to move before
the start of the school year so that
their kids can start the school year um
at their new school and so but if you
when I look at how we've been
performing
um you know fiscal year to date looking
only at transactions um from the
counties you know July which was for
June transaction
was up
5.4% August was up 2% September was up8
October was up 4.4 November was up 1.9
so we we're increasing those over the
same time period of the prior year um so
I think you're right it's it's starting
to give a little um and hopefully we
continue to see
that okay
um see no further questions we'll move
on okay
next tax is tobacco tax so the tobacco
tax is going to be
collected really in in
three almost four but three different
ways the first is um when you buy a pack
of cigarettes so that tax rate is .78
per pack of 20 cigarettes and
$223 per pack of 25 cigarettes and
that's done by a fixing a stamp to the
bottom of the pack the to tax is also
levied on other tobacco products which
are not ecigarettes so that would be
like your loose tobacco um pipe tobacco
that sort of thing and that rate is 65.0
3% of the wholesale sales price the
Third Way the tobacco tax is collected
it's kind of collected in two different
ways under the third way but that's for
ecigarettes and that tax rate went into
effect on January 1st of
2020 and so that is levied on both
closed systems and open systems so a
closed system is when um it's almost
like a pen like the ecigarettes that are
that are a pen um they're closed you
can't open them they are when they're
done you throw it out that is taxed at
$30 per milliliter on the volume of
liquid or other substance containing n n
nicotine sorry 30 cents that might have
been a Freudian slip we'll talk about
that in a second um
uh 30 cents per milliliter um an open
system is where you purchase the liquid
maybe in a little bottle and put it in a
device that heats it and um you replace
just the the liquid um in the bottle and
that is 8% of the wholesale sales
price so
um when you look at what's been going on
with tobacco tax revenue from 21 to 22
we saw an 88.2% decrease from 22 to 23
we saw a 6.1% decrease and from 23 to 24
we saw a 12.8%
decrease fiscal year 25 we're seeing
just about a 4% decrease over the prior
year so the the decreases that we've
been seeing in the past few years might
be slowing a
bit um what's been changing with the the
tobacco tax is the makeup
between tobacco tax on the packs of
cigarettes versus other tobacco products
so um for the first six months of the
year other tobacco products is just
under 20% so that's going to be your
loose tobacco and your ecigarettes
that's just under 20% of the revenue
that we've been receiving but if you go
back to 2013 it was just under 4% so
we're really seeing this shift in
Revenue away from traditional packs of
cigarettes and towards other tobacco
products including ecigarettes
um things that factors um that
contribute to the tobacco tax revenue
crossborder elasticity we have a very
low tobacco tax rate compared to
surrounding states so we see um a fair
amount of um tobacco products sold in
our states to consumers in other states
they'll come buy it here bring it home
because our rates are lower um just
public sentiment regards to um tobacco
consumption and the way it's consumed
again there's that shift away from maybe
more traditional packs of cigarettes and
towards this ecigarette Market um and
then availability of Menthol and
flavored tobacco products that are
banned in other states Massachusetts
it's a good example few years ago they
banned Menthol um and flavored tobacco
products and we saw a pretty significant
increase in demand in our state for
those
products looking at at the 10-year trend
on page
10 you will see from 2016 to 2019 or so
we saw you know a pretty consistent
year-over-year decline in
Revenue 2019 to 2021 we saw an increase
I think that's due to a couple of things
one the stress of the pandemic did not
help for people to consume uh tobacco
products less and also that was the time
period perod when the um ban on certain
products in other states occurred and so
we saw increased demand come to New
Hampshire from 2021 forward we are
seeing those revenues um
decline on page 11 this will show you
just tobacco tax stamp Revenue so just
the revenue due to people buying packs
of cigarettes you will see that jump
from 20 to
21 and then the decline the kind of more
normal levels um of what we see for
cigarette sales on page
12 you will see other tobacco
products so traditional other tobacco
products is in blue and then the yellow
or orangish color is the amount of
Revenue that were're receiving from
ecigarettes
so you will see that the blue has
increased a bit in recent years but
really A lot of the growth in other
tobacco products is due to um
ecigarettes
is is some of the decline based on the
fact that the tax on cigarettes is
higher than and I'm not sure how you
would compare it but it's basically
higher than the other tobacco products
and ecigarettes
so I think part of the decline in the
traditional tobacco tax revenue
is that
um you don't have the same new users of
cigarettes that you may have had in the
past and those new users of tobacco
products are opting towards ecigarettes
or other tobacco products at this point
they're to say it maybe more bluntly
kids aren't smoking cigarettes anymore
um and so but they are using nicotine
products that kind of fall in the other
tobacco tax area so I think that is why
you're seeing that decline in the
traditional pack of cig and those taxes
are relatively low correct the tax on so
the reason why the tax on other tobacco
products is 65.0 3% I know it's a bit of
an odd number um but when the tobacco
tax was put into place there was the tax
on the packs of cigarettes and there was
the tax on other tobacco
products as the tax on cigarettes
changed we we the state made the same
percentage change to the other tobacco
product rate so they've changed
proportionately um in that if the
tobacco tax stamp rate went up by 5%
then the other tobacco product rate went
up by 5% so that's why we're at that
weird 65.0
3% if you consider though for
ecigarettes
the if you try to equate the
um amount
of cigarettes how many cigarettes you
would have to smoke to to consume the
same amount of nicotine that's in an um
an
ecigarette those rates are not the same
so ecigarettes are taxed at a lower a
lower rate essentially and so what's
happening is those folks that are
starting to use tobacco products if
they're using an ecigarette they are
paying less for that same amount of of
nicotine if you will and so that's
definitely contributing to the decline
in Revenue thank you repres Aly yes
there was a
specific Demand by the Senate uh that we
lower the price of ecigarettes
considerably below what the house had
worked out as an
appropriate tax on that given that it
would get you off of the bad part of of
regular cigarettes but that it also
would addict a lot of young people to
nicotine and um it is a decision that
could be changed if people wanted
to right did you have a question R the
question is isn't that why ecigarettes
are comp are out competing a great deal
regular
cigarettes I don't know
necessarily
[Music]
um why I I there's you know probably
some anecdotal evidence that people do
view ecigarettes to be a healthier
alternative to cigarettes um but I will
say the the rates that are in place are
the original rates they have not changed
since the ecigarette uh tax went into
effect on January 1st of
tax one of the concerns we had we end up
up legislation for this coming turn was
the fact that wholesalers and retailers
are enforced and licensed by two
different agencies and so the question
whether a retailer product that they
have is and the wholesal pays correct so
the question was whether the retail
product was we bought from the wholesale
we actually paid the tax the state time
so we're actually have a bill
consolidate over to liquor um who who
currently does retail enforcement and
investigations and leave auditing with
Dr but would allow I think'll see that
that passes we consolidate betters
around these cigarettes and what's
whether not elicit products coming into
the state um that not beinged
going around it liquor has no way to
know on the retail if they don't license
uneven so that's a a great Point um the
the tobacco tax is collected by the
wholesaler um so the wholesalers are the
ones that purchase the stamps from the
Department of Revenue and AFF fix them
to the packages of cigarettes and for
other tobacco products um the wholesaler
charges the tax at the time that they
sell the product to the retailer and
then we collect the tax from the
wholesaler so um that's how the
collection works and so as Senator Lang
pointed out when you go into a retailer
who the tobacco retailers are licensed
by The Liquor Commission um there are
various ways it's easy when it's a stamp
on the bottom of a pack of cigarettes
you know right away whether or not the
tax has been paid but when it's other
tobacco products or ecigarettes we have
to start going through invoices and it
can make it more difficult to identify
um that the tax has been paid but yes
the the tax is paid by the wholesaler
pre-collected by the
wholesaler uh I skipped I skipped
represent thank you commissioner
as much as I'd
like um to differentiate between uh
speculative analysis and static
analysis with the recent tax increases
in Massachusetts on tobacco products
both uh Vapes and uh uh
Leaf do you have historical data to show
or to correlate between previous tax
increases in our bordering states and
our
revenues or is it possible to generate
that data there is some analysis that's
been done I've seen it um by the tax
Foundation um has compared rates in
different states and what what that
means the most recent um example is
probably when Massachusetts banned
Menthol and flavored products um that's
when we saw a pretty um New Hampshire
saw an increase and Rhode Island also
saw an increase in their sales um but
now I think we're starting to see that
kind of taper off so there can be sort
of like an initial where am I going to
get my product Oh I can drive to New
Hampshire I can drive to Rhode Island to
get it and then over time consumers find
other ways to get that product whether
they order it online switch to a
different product Etc so we tend to see
a bump initially but like we've seen in
the past couple years it's not
necessarily sustained um at consumers
are um more flexible in how they they
consume and so they'll change their
behaviors follow up thank you Mr chair
uh is there a correlation or has the
department done any correlation uh with
the anciliary sales uh a product at the
same time for example somebody in LOL
can't get their menthol cigarettes so
they come
to aot State Line in Hudson to pick it
up but they also say well Mark backs
just down the street uh is there any
correlation or any ability to even do
that I don't think we would have the
ability to do that the best information
we'd had was really just anecdotal from
the retailers that were on the border or
close to the border at the time that
Massachusetts ban went into effect um
they did say they started to see a
significant increase um in the Menthol
and flavored products um once that band
went into effect so that was really just
anecdotal through through our
conversations with some of the retailers
that is hard um so there is an
obligation in the statute that if you
purchase tobacco products online um that
you are the consumer is responsible for
remitting the tax and we have forms
available on our website to do that it
can be hard for us to to track that down
and so um we do a variety of of things
related to that we participate in um
tobacco tax administration groups that
exist across the country um and so we're
aware of larger players in the industry
and so we can kind of do specific
Outreach um and um auditing relative to
those those larger players and so we do
just try to keep up with kind of the
trends um but I think Senator Lang's
legislation will kind of go a long way
potentially to just
the more retailers that are selling in
the state whether they're online or
brick and mortar that are licensed or
monitored or regulated will go quite a
long way to making sure all of the tax
is
collected uh represent Aly thank you uh
our
committee on used to spend a lot of time
trying to figure out um how high we
could raise the tobacco tax in order to
to try to reduce smoking um and and to
get more revenue for the state because
in those days we wanted more Revenue in
the state
um
and Brian golob came to us and um he's
an expert in multivariant
analysis he showed us a major link
between the price of gas and the amount
of Revenue that we were getting from
tobacco and what and and what it was was
a large number of people in neighboring
states and even New York and New Jersey
coming up to us as the lowest price in
the country and a nice place to visit
and with a van and loading up and going
back
inter I think we had something like that
going on at one point with
Brandy from New York state but um that
that I think is pretty much in the past
now but that's what we were
doing okay um I'm going to take two more
questions because we need we're getting
we can look into that breakout when we
come before the committee with
additional detail yep you're welcome
okay one last question representative
ORS thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question so piggy backing off
of what uh representative Amy was
talking about do we have an idea how
much tax revenue the New Hampshire
Advantage gives us like we know we get
Li extra liquor sales from the
surrounding states we talking about
cigarettes do we have monetary value
that we can put on that I think the tax
Foundation report attempts to do that
for cigarettes um so attempts to
quantify um and we can bring that um to
the committee as well but attempts to
quantify essentially how much of our
revenue is for cigarettes or tobacco
products that are leaving the state so
we can bring that
information thank you I think we'll move
okay so we have a couple of quick taxes
here on page 13 and 14 um you know
wanting to be thorough and make sure
that you have um all of the taxes
covered um and then we'll talk about
business taxes we saved um the biggest
one for last so on page 13 the utility
property tax is imposed on utility
property at a rate of
$660 per th000 of value and that value
is determined by the Department of
Revenue
as of April 1st of each
year um audited upt Revenue over the
past 3 years we saw a 13.4% increase in
21 over 22 a slight decrease from 22 to
23 a 99.1% increase um from 23 to 24 and
then for the first 6 months of this year
we are 10.6% above plan um but flat
compared to the prior year
our tax year 24 assessments were $
48.8 million and that's based on a
utility property value of 7.3 billion so
this tax collects somewhere between $45
and $50 million a year um factors that
can affect it obviously if we have more
um renewable energy facilities come
online or any other utility um property
come online that increases the amount of
taxable property the valuation of the
utility property because the tax is a
direct effect um of the value and then
Energy prices supply and demand those
things will affect the profits of the
utility properties and that will
therefore affect their value so
relatively small tax but just wanted to
thorough yes represent good question Mr
chairman commissioner does the Broadband
expansion that we're seeing in the state
go on you utility property tax or does
it go on to the communications tax so
the Broadband expansion is going to be
internet access um and so we will jump
to CST and we'll talk about that there
if that works for you
Senator um those are going to be yes yes
correct yep water sewer that all
upt okay um okay sounds good we'll move
on communication Services tax so
communication Services tax is a tax of
7% on all way all two-way communication
services this tax runs about 30 $
million a year um pretty consistent we
are slightly below plan year-to date but
we're about
4.3% um ahead of Prior year um things
that can affect the communication
Services tax obviously decrease in
landlines um for a while you may have
had a cell phone and a landline um so
both of those are taxable now if you
don't have a landline and you only have
a cell phone now only your cell phone's
taxable um modern pricing and purchasing
trends for Wireless Communications so
and this is going to partially answer uh
representative Schamberg's question
um CST we tax two-way communication but
we do not tax internet access so that is
prohibited under federal law the CST
used to tax internet access and we were
grandfathered in um federally to be able
to do that but we have since um we know
no longer tax internet access and so we
can't go back to taxing it again um
so Broadband expansion is really
internet access you know from a CST
perspective um so where Modern pricing
and purchasing trends for Wireless
Communications come in is not all of
your cell phone bill is
taxable Only The Voice and text portion
not the data portion because we can't
tax internet access
and what we've seen in recent years is
more and more wireless communication
companies are attributing more of your
bill to
data right more and more of your bill is
so that you can surf the web on your
phone less of your bill is related to
actual Voice or
text that being said VoIP and video
conferencing is two-way communication it
happens over the internet but it's still
two-way communication and so that is
taxable so we've just kind of seen a bit
of a shift in the communication Services
tax
landscape um but historically it it was
higher but in the past few years it's
been pretty consistent right around $30
million a
year sounds good I'm just going to take
two questions at most on this one
because the business taxes I'm sure are
going have a lot of questions represent
shambar thank you Mr chairman thank you
commissioner I guess my question was
when they put up more poles or add new
lines for the
Broadband is that part of the assessment
value that goes into the utility it
depends on who owns the poles and who
owns the wires um typically with the
Broadband expansion it depends on the
area whether the poles are there already
and they're just stringing wires versus
new poles so it it depends on the area
that you're looking at
okay one more question seeing none we'll
go on to business taxes okay this was so
that you would stay all the way to the
end um business
taxes okay so there's two business taxes
we have the business Enterprise tax and
the business profits tax the bet or the
business Enterprise tax is assessed on
the sum of all compensation interest and
dividends that are paid by the business
the business profits tax is assessed on
the income
from the conduct of business activity
within the state so more of a
traditional income
tax the BPT conforms to the Internal
Revenue code in effect on December 31st
2018 for taxable periods beginning on or
after December 1st of 2020 I put that in
there and we'll talk more about this
when we come before the Committees um
but New Hampshire follows what's called
Static Conformity we pick an internal
revenue code and that's the Internal
Revenue code that we follow um the
legislature we report to you in March of
every year on changes that have occurred
federally and the legislature can make
the decision to update the reference to
the code or not other states are um
what's called rolling Conformity and
they pick up all the changes that happen
at the federal level New Hampshire has
opted to to be fixed Conformity so that
we can look at the changes at the
Federal level the federal code and
decide whether or not we want to adopt
those um and we can make the option to
adopt some or not all so again we'll
talk about that more when we come before
the committee but as you're hearing in
the Press about potential changes to the
internal revenue Co code at a federal
level that's not something necessarily
that would impact New Hampshire
immediately we would have to make the
adjustment to the Internal Revenue code
reference in order to pick up those
changes at the federal
level uh fact that affect business taxes
obviously the economy um federal tax
reform and stimulus programs we've seen
you know a fair amount of of money in
the economy over the past few years
related to the covid-19 stimulus
programs I think that has largely made
its way through the economy um and is to
the point where it is in a less liquid
state at this point which is one of the
reasons why I think we're seeing a
decrease in business taxes which I'll
talk about in a little bit
um mergers and Acquisitions as companies
merge and expand that's generally good
for the tax base um any credits or
exemptions that exist in the law can
obviously impact how that um how our
taxes are collected and that would go
along with statutory changes so as the
legislature makes changes to the
business taxes um that will impact our
revenue and as bills come before the
Committees with statutory changes we'll
obviously work closely with you to to um
identify potential
impacts on page 16 just two um
legislative changes that have happened
recently that I wanted to
highlight one is the cap on credit
carryovers so businesses make estimated
payments to the state and then at the
end of the year they file their final
return sometimes they've paid in more
money than they owe and they have an
option at that point to either keep that
money on account and say you hold it
I'll use that later or they can ask for
it as a
refund for taxable periods ending on or
after December 31st of
2022 the law now says if you want to
keep it on account you can't keep more
than 500% of your liability so if your
liability last year was
$100 then your credit carryover cannot
be more than
500 um and this was partially due to a
decision by the legislature because our
credit carryover liability was growing
there were many companies that were
choosing to um leave their money on
account and that liability was growing
pretty significantly so the cap is
currently at
500% that will go to
250% for tax periods ending onor after
December 31st of 20129 and will go down
to 100% for taxable periods ending onor
after December 31st of
2031 so what that means is that the
state has less of a potential liability
for monies that it would owe back to
businesses but once this cap went into
effect in this past year we saw pretty
significant increase in our refunds
because if you have more than 500% on
your account we have to refund the
difference to you um again we can talk
about this more in detail when we come
before committees but that credit
carryover cap on one hand reduces the
state's liability but we have seen that
it has reduced the amount of money that
we're needing to send back to businesses
and that might be just a bit of a timing
issue as businesses get more accustomed
to this cap um but at least that's what
we saw in fiscal year 24 um the only
other thing I would noce we saw a slight
reduction in the BPT rate from 7.6% to
7.5% for taxable periods ending honor
after December 31st of 2023
and historic rates are are shown in the
17 you will see fiscal year
2015 through fiscal year 24 business tax
revenue and I would call your attention
I think to the column in the middle that
says change in Revenue
percent and what you'll see here is that
business taxes can be volatile they are
our largest source of Revenue and they
are also probably our most
volatile um so you you see in fiscal
year 2016 we had almost a 25% increase
in revenue from the prior year and then
2017 it fell almost
9% um in recent years you will see
though that we revenues have been
growing so a 41.3% increase in revenue
from 20 to 21 22% % from 21 to 22 just
under 3% from 23 to 24 and then we saw a
slight decrease in revenue from
23 to 24 for the first 6 months of the
fiscal year we are 155% below plan and
18 factors that imp
revenues so looking a bit to the past as
I mentioned economic stimulus I think
has driven revenues over the past few
years there a lot of money that was put
into the economy and it made its way
through in a variety of
ways um also as I mentioned legislative
changes that CCO cap needing to increase
um or refund more money then we had
historically and also we've seen a
couple of changes um in how we a portion
business tax revenue in New Hampshire so
what that means is when you are a
business that's operating in multiple
States apportionment is how we tell you
that you need to figure out what portion
of your Revenue p is revenue that New
Hampshire should um receive tax on uh
commissioner steep if you don't mind I
think we'll take qu on this one
questions in between because uh a lot of
slides uh
represent uh thank you commissioner uh
you talking about being 15 below plan
which is fine because that up and down
and whatever uh often times we've seen
that reverse itself dramatically in
April
which we'll
see but you did make a comment regarding
the uh availability availability of
stimulus funds our recent
M2 comment came out saying that there
was so much money in the market that
the value of each dollar has shrunk so
much that you needed more to cover the
same cost of something that what has
been the effect of the increase of the
money
supply the the currency on
hand to the New Hampshire
expenditures as it cost us more money as
it cost us less money or real money not
dollar-wise but more pieces of currency
as it
were I don't know if I know the answer
question so where I'm coming at the
stimulus money is is understanding how
that money makes its way to taxable
profits of businesses where we then
receive business profits tax rep Rue or
business Enterprise Revenue if if the
stimulus Money Paid wages and or
dividends and and we receive the money
that way what I what I'm feeling like
has happened is
that the money has made its way sort of
beyond that taxable profits level and
that a lot of that stimulus money is in
Investments and so let's say it's it's
in Investments and an investment company
would potentially that would make it to
its bottom line for taxable profits but
maybe that money when it started got
spent at a retail store and that retail
increased I think what's happened is the
stimulus money is not hitting the bottom
line taxable profits in as many
originally and so that's why not that
the money is not there I mean it is
still in the in the economy it didn't
evaporate but how is it is it still
impacting the taxable profits of
businesses maybe for a lot of people the
stimulus money is now in their home
right they used that money they did home
renovations they saw their their real
estate tax assessments increase right
and that's but you know when it's at
that point when it's in someone's home
that's not a a taxable business profit
at the end of the
day so that that's what I kind of mean
of of the money kind of running through
it it's almost like past the point of
where we would see it come in as
Revenue if that makes sense yes thank
but to get back to the question is when
you increase the volume
M each
less building the reservoir over here
sure because there's so much here yep
that in order to equal what you were
spending
yesterday you have to spend more
today is that the situation in which we
find
ourselves I think that could be
contributing to it certainly
that right when the the money came into
the economy originally we
hadn't the drops were bigger I guess to
use your
analogy right when that when the
stimulus money first hit the economy we
hadn't seen inflation increase the the
drops were bigger okay now as we've
worked our way through the past few
years we've seen inflation increase
we've seen prices increase those drops
smaller thank you maybe repres me thank
you uh it doesn't look like you're
covering the shift in in when the
company's revenues hit the
Dr uh and could you say something about
the two to threee gap between when the
company earns money and when you see an
increase or decrease in revenues we're
going to get to that in a couple slides
oh you will we just didn't get there I
looked briefly and couldn't find it
we'll move uh one last question Senator
Lang
yeah
also grants are given the pay right to
keep people employed so the state didn't
at
this correct so we're not see that grow
got we see 21 22 because were invested
we saw grow
now correct I think you're you're
exactly right and we'll talk about that
um also on the next slide um so just to
finish off slide 18 you know things that
that we look at in terms of future
business tax revenue like I said we'll
work with you all closely on any future
legislation um and any statutory changes
that would be implemented relative to
the business profits tax or business
Enterprise tax revenue um things we're
just generally watching in the economy
Supply train chain
constraints um you know disruption
Imports in factories anytime you hear
Rumblings of strike
um or impact on Goods moving in any way
shape or form that's something that that
could impact the economy same with any
potential tariffs or
sanctions um inflation rate seems to
maybe be coming down a little bit at
least has tempered a bit um but
something we'll keep an eye on and then
low unemployment rate again is is good
um for business profits tax and business
Enterprise tax we'll keep looking at the
potential interest rate changes global
geopolitical stability
or instability maybe is a better term to
use there um and just general economic
uncertainty although it it maybe doesn't
feel as uncertain as it has I think
Senator Lang is right that we may just
be kind of at a new normal um after
years of growth and flipping to page 19
you can kind of see
that if you look at
2019 and you look at 202 4 and you
ignore 21 22 and
23 you kind of just see a nice
trajectory there um and that just an
underlying growth in the economy and so
it is I do think we're just kind of
experiencing a little bit of a reset and
we're not going to continue to see this
year-over-year growth that we saw in you
know
2122 um continue and that we're kind of
at a bit of a new normal
here on page 20 this gets a little bit
towards um representative aly's point in
terms of the timing um and when we
typically see
revenues so what you'll notice on page
20 is
that the largest portion of these bar
charts the biggest color is red and and
read our estimates so businesses are
required um when they meet certain
conditions to pay for quarterly
estimates to the state that's how we get
the majority of our business tax revenue
it comes in the form of
estimates unfortunately estimates
contain the least amount of information
it gives me the business name the tax
period end date and an amount there's no
explanation on the estimates of why
they're making that estimated payment um
we don't know that information until the
business files the return so only once a
business files the return do we get all
of that supporting detail about what has
gone on in that business during the year
for a calendar year tax filer um their
initial returns are due in either March
or
April however if they have paid in in
their estimates the amount of money that
they owe they get an automatic
seven-month extension to file their
return so we receive many returns in the
fall in the October November time frame
that's almost a year after their tax
period ended in almost two years since
the tax period
started so to representative aly's point
you know we're receiving money every
quarter
but we don't always really know why or
what's going on with that money
until at least 10 months after or so as
much as 10 months after the tax period
ends and so that's where we can see that
bit of a delay in terms of really
understanding what's going on which is
why it's so important for you all to
hear from everybody else that's going to
talk after me over the next day and a
half to understand you know what they're
hearing or seeing or what they um not to
be about what's going on in the economy
because most of what we get is old news
it moving on to page
21 the important thing really to know
here is that the vast majority of
business tax revenue comes from
corporations um so we do have some
Partnerships and proprietorships that
that pay business tax revenue but the
vast majority comes from uh corporations
and the vast majority of that
Corporation Revenue comes from large
multinational
corporations page 22 is just going
to give you um just a graph on how
business profits tax versus business
Enterprise tax has been performing over
the past few years and really the the
thing I just want to highlight is the
significant increase in business profits
um over the past few years and that you
can see by the increase in the blue line
um we most of the the growth in the
business taxes as a whole has been
relative to the business profits tax as
as corporations um have seen significant
years um and
then on page
23 this is just kind of a way to see
everything in one place together all of
the taxes that we talked about um again
you'll see the majority of our Revenue
comes in the form of business taxes most
of our other taxes have been fairly
years on page 24 just because again I
want to be thorough this includes the
interest and dividends tax that tax has
been repealed um as of January 1
2025 we will receive indd Revenue um in
April as returns for um the 1231 24 year
end um are filed so we're not done
receiving indd revenue and we will
continue to receive it you know in the
future um through various compliance
efforts and just as folks um not
everyone files timely so we'll we'll see
indd Revenue Trail off but I did just
include it here um for the purposes of
everyone understanding because there is
indd revenue in fiscal year
26 this again is just to give you kind
of a summary of where we are in fiscal
year 25 to date so through the end of
December we have collected a total of
um. 6 million
plan for the first six months was just
over a billion so we're about eight and
a half 88.8% below
plan but in the last column I would just
note plan still has us collecting more
than half of the revenue for the year so
again as I said earlier not all of our
taxes come in consistently every month
or consistently in the first half of the
Year versus the second so as
representative erery alluded to with
business taxes we are behind but almost
60% of the revenue is still due to
become to come in in the second half of
the year and that's through estimated
payments in April returns in March and
April and then returns and extensions in
March and April and then another round
of estimates in June so again we are
behind but plan would still have us
collecting the majority of the revenue
in the second half of the
year I mentioned just another one to
give as an example I mentioned that R
doesn't flow in evenly month to month so
you can see that the first half of the
year is stronger for us for R um and we
expect less than half of the ret Revenue
to come in in the second half of the
year which generally makes sense as
you're talking January through June um
you still have those cold dark winter
months um where transaction volumes are
low in on the last slide in case you're
curious um other taxes that we
administer um that don't hit the general
and education trust fund in the same way
that the ones that we covered the
Medicaid enhancement tax Nursing
Facility quality assessment the railroad
tax and private railroad car excavation
tax Timber tax and the Statewide
education property tax so these are ones
you won't need to worry about
necessarily doing Revenue estimates for
but in case you ever wanted to know um
the whole picture of Dr this will give
it to you excellent um any questions
uh thank you commissioner uh going back
to the the business and profits tax uh
in response to some recent news articles
or editorial articles it seems to me
that Dr has some correlation
someplace
regarding the
percentage of Revenue you said roughly
60% is is going to be collected over the
next several months fine
understood where do we stand now
compared to other and this minus5
doesn't that's year to date but
regarding mone's coming in and money and
uh being below plan my recollection is
is that annually we're below plan at
this
point uh in most instances except for
the recent uh uh after we cut the
property taxes there was a or business
taxes there was a huge rebat of money
take that little blip out but it seems
to me that this time of year is normally
a negative time of year or low time of a
year as opposed to the next couple of
months is that an accurate assessment of
where we are now we can look into that I
don't want to I don't want to answer
definitively without doing the math cuz
I like math um but I will say I will say
just as a reminder
um this the second year in the biennium
is the oldest Revenue estimate if you
will right so so the the fiscal year the
right and you could jump to essentially
the least accurate so these were Revenue
estimates you know that were done two
years ago at this point and so right
yeah two and a half years ago so the
second year of the bium that's the
hardest year to develop plan for um and
then when you're you're in it you
haven't adjusted planned with any of the
information that's coming at any time in
the in the last two and a half years so
we can look at how ta How revenues
typically Trend at this time of year
compared to how we end the year and that
will be helpful as we talk about Revenue
estimates because that's part of how we
develop them um but I will say just a
reminder that you know this is this is
the these are the oldest estimates when
you get into the second year of the bium
representative commissioner do you have
a way to tell how much of the business
taxes are collected
by buses that
areed
inire so the the way the easiest way for
us to answer that question is we have um
when you talk about
corporations we have um a form called
the 1120 which mirrors the federal 1120
for corporations and then we have an
1120 Wei and we stands for Water's Edge
and those that 1120 we form is a
different form and those are the
multinational businesses and so that's
the easiest breakdown that we have and
we do break down that information in our
annual report and we can certainly bring
that information um to the
committee follow up do you
mucher I will say the majority of the
revenue that we receive for business
taxes comes from wat's Edge corporations
so the way the Medicaid enhancement Tax
Works is kind of two-part we collect the
tax from the hospitals um based on the
the tax base and the rate that's in
statute and then we essentially turn
that money over to
HHS um for their use relative to
disproportionate share and provider
payments and the whole statutory scheme
there so we're really only on the front
end um and so to the extent that there's
any conversations about changing um the
base to which the Medicaid enhancement
tax is applied or the rate at which it's
applied that's where we would get
involved um and then on the spend side
that would be with the Department of
Health and Human
Services represent El thank you uh in
the past
until maybe two terms ago uh Ways and
Means would do updates of estimates when
we saw things
changing um we we been a little
bit
uh messed up uh in the last couple of
years and uh I think that it would
probably be helpful if we started that
back up
again that's at the call of the chair
the chair decides whether things are
changing enough that we need to look at
them the way we're going to be looking
at them now yeah well as I look into my
crystal ball we'll we'll see how see how
that goes but uh certainly our first
step is to come up with our Revenue
estimates for the next bium and then
we'll keep close a close eye on how
things are going and if things are
changing um you know in a in a way
that's significant obviously we will and
I don't but we're once we receive them
um we usually put together a report um
of how they've come in um and we will
share that um we'll do our
Lang your presentation online on 19 and
20 Pages I'm going start with 20
look
at it's netted out when it's reported it
is netted out when it's reported correct
and so I failed to mention that on page
20 you'll see that in that larger Orange
Box um at the bottom um which is going
to net out those are the refunds and so
we saw almost a 90% increase in refunds
in fiscal year 2024 and that's largely
due to the credit carry over cap follow
so given that we're not actually going
to be we're changing the credit carry
for a few years out now um we should
expect that in 26 and 27 that
orange years so while we may still
collect 1.4 here the actual carry
refunds are they should be they should
be as long as the the hope is that
businesses learn I mean there's nothing
there nothing stopping them from making
the estimated payments that produce that
greater than 500% credit carryover um
but presumably there would be a change
in behavior and so we should see those
refunds um decline hopefully their CPAs
or whoever is doing their accounting is
informing them that you don't have to
get it down to 250 yet right so and
those for those of you who are new this
uh the 250 was going to be I believe
starting this year right uh but we
pushed it out five years uh knowing that
or worrying that uh things were changing
too quickly we wanted to change that
behavior yes represent ORS thank you Mr
chair and thanks again for taking my
question so just out of curiosity first
of all this money that the state has
been able to hold on to that uh is going
to eventually start to go down obviously
are we going to lose interest money on
that I mean are we getting interest on
those funds we're
holding yes um yes the short answer is
yes it's in it's in the and the
treasurer we'll speak to this it's in
the the bank account like anything else
um and so yes there'd be a reduction in
in interest income to the extent that
that's being earned thank you follow-up
question followup and so on the business
um
19 uh we're looking at it looks like on
page 16 we see that the tax rates
obviously gone down over time we've cut
the tax rate from 72% now we're at
0.55% but the revenues continue to climb
so are we looking at this being
sustainable in other words as we've cut
the rate we can continue to grow the
revenue it looks like and what would we
attribute that to so um the rates have
you know decreased as you're showing on
um on page 16 um but I think we've also
seen a significant increase over this
time period of just the base in the
economy um and so it's it can be very
hard to separate those two things from
each other um so when we
if there are any bills this session to
change the business tax rates we treat
it as a static analysis where we just
take the base and apply the new rate and
so a reduction in the rate would mean a
reduction in Revenue we don't factor in
whether the rate reduction would be
sufficient enough to change behavior
that would result in a larger base um we
don't go that way we just treat it as as
strictly um a static analysis but I
because it is very hard to separate at
out what are just underlying changes in
the base
versus whether or not that change would
occur with or without the tax rate
change yeah okay because having done
taxes in another state i' I learned that
as the tax rate dropped more people were
willing to step up and pay the tax
versus hide it or avoid it so thank
youate it I'm going to take one more
question from representative Aly and
then just realize that we will have Dr
back for a deeper dive uh on these taxes
representative
yeah I just the page
17 really shows you something about this
on in 16 we had a major increase in
1514 uh in in the companies on that was
the year that New
Hampshire on grw GRE to the same level
from the depth of the recession of the
Great Recession uh to the same level as
the rest of the country which because it
has income taxes and sales taxes gets
more immediate uh
response
um
then the next one was in
18 we owe that to the on the tax cuts
and jobs act which gave a very large
amount of money to the corporations and
the rich and richest people in the
country and on we were able to tax
it I think no other state had a business
profits tax the way we do that allowed
them to do as much of that and they they
also they don't
have uh very high corporate
taxes
um then um the next major increase was
as we came out of the out of the worst
of the
pandemic
um represent I'm sorry we're behind
funds
so so I just want to remind people that
we do have that that weight between when
the increase happens and the increase is
recorded
here I was say something well we we're
um almost 15 minutes behind so I want to
move on we will have Dr back as I said
we can and we'll also when we're doing
our Revenue estimates be discussing how
economic factors are going to affect our
Revenue estimates thank you uh
okay uh next we have uh the state
oh my goodness gracious we're getting
Hightech
now I can read the
HDM I think we're gonna have a slide
too yeah she's passing on a hard C
we can turn off the
um can we turn off the the
long as what's up there is here we
good morning Mr chairman and um and
everyone attending uh this um this
economic briefing uh for the record
State Treasurer Monica mapelli um so
today I I will provide you with an
update of our our state of finances our
cash reserves and our ratings and
bonding so um as all of you know um the
state was um upgraded last year by one
of the rating agencies and I'm often
asked what contributed to to that
upgrade so um I would like to um uh
provide this presentation today um
through that from that perspective um so
this this slide um really uh speaks to
the reasons uh the state was upgraded um
um we've the state um has benefited from
healthy economic conditions strong
financial management strong cash
levels um so um the first component is
is really how state has been our economy
has been um very strong um I don't want
to spend too much time on this SL
because I know you you have experts
coming and talking about uh the economy
but um but just to highlight what really
takes part of of of the rating process
uh the state really uh benefits from a
diverse economy diverse sectors um
sectors in technology Health Care
education um the good news about being
diverse is is one the one sector doesn't
perform well than the others um uh do
fine so that's uh the benefit of being
Diversified um so that's seen as a as a
positive um our aging population is
still a concern um but the state has
benefited from a population increase
we've had about 2.3% increase since
2020 and um really what the um in in
that is our pacing compared to our
neighbor States um so having a working
uh growing a working age population will
continue to boost our economy um and
again we've enjoyed um a robust economy
with low unemployment uh High per capita
personal income and all of that is
conducive to generate contribute to
growth so the state has also um again
benefit from um all of us being part of
um manitary Finance as well um a strong
financial management um we've been able
to provide balanced budgets uh we have
diverse uh Revenue sources we're able to
control our expenditures well we've been
able to add to our reserves all of that
has benefited the state so um what you
see um in this chart is um how revenues
have had a positive trend over the last
10 years except during the short period
of um during the pandemic um the brief
um recession that we had um we also know
that um if you look at 21 22 and 23 um
Cost Containment measures in 21 and a
conservative budget in 22 allow for a
sign significant Surplus um during the
recovery and that um happen at the end
of that bium so with with that um
addition with those additional revenues
we've been able to um add funds to our
rain day fund which is a key component
of our credit
rating um in addition to state has been
able to um use in our Co fund Co funds
and um the additional revenues um the
state has made key Investments um in in
various sectors and housing uh water
infrastructure Broadband um again while
being able to add more money to our
reserves all of that is all of these
Investments are key to continue boosting
our economy and that's what uh Mr Mike K
called the legislative specials in 20 in
22 23 and 24 we've had additional
Appropriations as you uh as you can see
and um again all of those are uh very
good Investments for our state
um again taking advantage of the
additional Revenue that we have um
collected over the last few
years so uh unfortunately as we just
heard our fiscal year 23 25 revenues are
coming lower and plan and as you can see
that 2024 expenditures um are higher
than the previous Trend so um you know
um that's uh clearly a challenge for all
of us to to try to um you know figured
out how we're going to going to manage
that uh but uh also the rating agencies
will will look at how we uh handle um
that in the short term and obviously in
the L long term um they'll be watching
how we um plan for our YDC claims and
any additional pressures uh regarding da
education funding uh and other uh
budgetary pressures for from other um
social
programs they'll also be watching to
um you know any plans that the state has
to replace um the revenues uh from the
interest and dividend STX going forward
again right now we have uh revenues
lower than planned but we also um losing
a significant um source of
Revenue that's on the general f side on
the education trust fund side um the
only thing I would like to U mention
here is how um um the the education
trust fund obviously has had a positive
trend over the last uh 10 and five years
particular um the education trust fund
has benefited from the outperformance in
revenue and that has um which um we have
been able to um have a positive uh fund
balance over the last few years if you
look at uh 20 20 and 2021 um the green
bars Show additional expenditures likely
those are Co expenditures and then and
fisure
24 um the the funding formula uh changed
and and so that added additional funding
to um the education trust fund which was
an increase of about 13 uh
133% again that's just a a a overall
picture of our finances and how uh our
revenues and our expenditures have
performed um over the last 10 years um
that also the state has benefited from
um strong cash reserves uh clearly um
the um the fact that we've received
additional F funds and the additional
Revenue we've collected um changed the
picture of our cash position um this is
a bus slide um but um what I what I like
to highlight is um I like to include
year 20 in this and this SL which is the
yellow line in this chart and if you can
see uh if you see the beginning of the
FIS year um we were averaging about 8
800 million in our cash position and
then um with the additional revenue and
additional funding that we've received
over the last uh five years are or cash
position um increased in significantly
um we reach um in FIS year 24 we reach
um the point of 2.8 billion in our
funds so um our healthy our healthy cash
position uh coupled with higher interest
rates uh we've been able to generate
generate significant um investment
income we created 95 or 100 million to
the general fund in FIS year 24 um I
think it was about 65 and
23 um fiscal year 25 levels are are
lower and that's the Gray Line uh right
now as this current current information
is we have about 1.7 billion in our cash
position um we are um about 15% less
compared to last year um which is the
effect of less revenues and and and
steady uh expenditures expenditures
being a little bit higher um than again
the previous
Trend um even with that um you know for
FIS year 25 we still anticipate about 80
million in investment income but then
again in FIS year 26 27 the picture will
change um you know we may we may have
about half of what we're anticipating
this year um interest rates um will
eventually come down and normalize uh it
doesn't look like in this year they're
going to be drastically reduced um at
least that's what uh we've been hearing
um but again eventually they will come
to a normal normal pace and the
prediction is is is going to be about 3%
run the revenue stabilization account
this is definitely a key component of
our rating um as you can see we've been
able to add um significant amounts over
the last few years again the additional
revenues have contributed to adding the
Surplus to the rainy day fund
um the one the one thing I would like to
um highlight uh to this SC is um the
really the the Rainy Define is really
what is called the revenue stabilization
account and and I'd like to uh emphasize
that because um this is really the tool
the state has um in the event we have
Revenue show Falls or or projected
deficit unfortunately it's not this is
not another fund or or a fund that we
can use for particular initiatives this
is a really important component of our
of our credit profile uh is seen by the
rating agenc is seen by our investors
how much we're able to um again having
an emergency fund in the EV in events of
again uh you know fiscal challenges and
economic
downturns um so right now the
2925 million that we have is about 7% of
the current capacity and the law says
that we can have about we can have 10%
of revenues um of the last by Anum that
would be about 400 million if we wanted
to reach that capacity and a couple of
points that I I want to make um you know
the the the median according to S&P
Global is 15% of Revenue so the states
uh hold that that amount and and another
point that um our financial advisor um
you know brings it to my my attention is
is the fact that moodies um uh when they
when they um review the state the state
scores really high um apparently we we
get a score of a AAA rated um entity but
because they don't believe we have
enough money and in our reserves they
remove a point from us so that's um you
know something to keep in mind how we
could one day be a triple R triple um
state I'm sorry we have one question on
that yes representative yeah thank you I
just want to understand the uh today's
state are we AAA now or going to be AAA
um so it's it's in one of the slides um
but we are
so the three and I'll jump to that
quickly uh so those are the ratings that
we have so um we are below AAA but we
are consider um investment grade um our
bonds are consider investment grade so
it's uh double A1 from Moody's uh
doublea plus uh from Fitch and uh doua
plus um assessed by S&P S&P was the one
that um upgraded us uh last year we were
uh doublea but now we're um uh doublea
plus with an a stable Lo and I and I'll
talk about this um in a few
minutes uh we it looks like we have a
couple questions if it's all right sure
um representa
ol when you're talking about the bound
rting uh Madam
Treasurer it doesn't cost us anything at
a at a double a plus rating as opposed
to a AAA rating uh and that would it's
only a few million dollars that would
change that into the reserve fund if I'm
not mistaken
so does it really make any difference to
the taxpayer in New
Hampshire yes thank you for the question
um you know again is the the have being
a AAA uh rated entity um will be really
um um you know something to to be proud
of but but you're right um the current
rating that we have allow us to um again
still have um low cost borrowing um you
know every we again it's it's just the
fact that investors um will be were more
attractive to them so they'll provide it
really is during our bond sales you know
our our our bonds become more
competitive so the more competitive we
are we receive lower cost um our yields
will be lower and we'll eventually pay
less for our debt service so um it
really does benefit again it's just um
you know just trying to have a better
Financial uh picture um if we were a
triaa um rated um State uh we will
definitely benefit from that um
represent Aly thank you um this also
benefits all of the municipalities and
the counties correct
when they go out to bond yes
um some of them go out to to um on their
own and others go through the municipal
Bond Bank um the municipal Bond Bank
benefits from our rating uh slightly so
I will say yes um uh not very directly
but indirectly they're um they're
attached because of the um um I'm
forgetting the the the term right now
but but they're they're linked to us
because we provide that guarantee thank
you and what I want wanted to ask was uh
what happened in
20 22 that cut our rainy day fund in
half I don't remember it yes um and so
that was uh the one time um reduction um
that was those funds were sent to or to
create the um the YDC settlement fund
that was a time when um we had again
reserves and and it was a a a decision
um that money was um going to be used
from that fund and that's one of the
reason I mentioning the importance of
the rainy day fund um you know we can
certainly um speak to to rating agencies
and others um you know the reason why we
do you know make a decision like that
but um it is just not um recommended I
should say again the day fund is there
for when we need it economic down terms
come they do happen shortall Revenue
shortfalls as we can see you know right
now revenues are coming below plan they
do happen so we need to be prepared for
that and that's the tool we have
available represent shamberg thank you
Mr chairman thank you madam Treasurer uh
just a quick
question revenues that come in taxes
that come in what do you invest in uh
the bond market the mutual funds or and
the stabilization fund is it actual cash
or is it invested
also yes thank you for the question we
invest everything and um we do have
investment policies for um our operating
funds so they they behave differently
than the rainy day fund the rainy day
fund is here to stay a little bit longer
so we invest in the same type of
Investments but the rainy day fund has a
a longer duration so we can um invest in
a in a in a different way but uh we we
do have our investment policy is is
mainly fixed income us treasuries uh us
feral agencies uh corporate bonds um
anything that is um um investment grade
investment um you know we have to ensure
we we meet the objectives of first
safety liquidity and um try to um
achieve uh a High um rate of
return representative om yeah thank you
I have followup on the ratings and I
like wonder if you could give us a
comment on how the ratings affect our
actual interest rates on long-term bonds
say triaa double a single a what kind of
a percent impact would that imply again
is is is really the the fact that right
now we have um significant reserves that
that is a is a good thing is is like
having a significant cash our balance
sheet we that's so that's a positive for
the career rating um obviously all of it
together and I'll move to to De in a
minute but all of the components
together allows us to to have a strong
rating um if one of those components
don't behave you know if if they don't
act correctly for just for saying it
that way um obviously that could impact
so yes thank you for the question we do
have um everything that so we we we use
our our all of our banks we have we do
business
with most of the banks in New Hampshire
um so the the larger banks that allow us
to um um provide the services the
banking services we need um we do
business uh with with them and we and
and we maintain with them um right now
again the the composition of the cash
exchanging but we have about um um we
have about 400 million with them right
now um with our Community Banks we
maintain a separate program where our
Community Banks and that is um we
started that uh in
20120 um we have about 130 million with
our Community Bank so that's I don't
have the percentage with me right now
but it's about 130 million in
in
um again our are and so we've had that
for for a while um the way we are going
to um um again now that our cashes the
the the the cash is changing uh the
composition of our cash is changing a
little bit we may need to reduce some of
those funds with those those Banks but
not not drastically I will say thank you
you're welcome Senator
Lang whole idea about B is that we have
high cash avilability in our renate
fund stabilization fund as well as
having low debt um drives up our bond
rating that Bond rating will help us
with future bonds that by keeping our
our interest charge lower and theary to
that is that the municipalities also
benefit from that by having lower
Municipal rates and which in the long
term means that we're paying less of
debt service and getting more value
excellent
um so so speaking of that I can move to
we'll move on if that's if that's okay
um I'll move just to to our debt levels
again we we do have um we're very
conservative when it comes to that um we
benefit from again having a low low de
burden um the the rating agencies also
evaluate our pension and a
post-employment benefit uh liability but
I I'll speak uh to that in a moment um
so if you look at this chart um the
again the trend and you can see our our
debt levels have decreased over the last
few years um the blue line is uh our net
net tax support debt which is debt repay
with General funds and right now it's
about 500 million um the rating agency
is also look at our pens our pension um
liability and our post-employment
benefits liability um they don't
consider that
um as being um too low but um the rating
agencies uh feel comfortable with u the
plan New Hampshire has um the fact that
we are going to um there's a plan to
repay the unfunded liability uh in 14
years um our funding ratio is increasing
and we obviously have more assets and
the trust fund the portion related to
New Hampshire is only uh um about a
billion dollars compared to the five
billion that the entire unfunded
liability um you know the the total
unfunded liability the portion of the
state is just 1 billion so that's
considered and and and and used as part
of our you know again the evaluation of
our state's um debt
burden um the next the next page is uh
is really just a summary of our Deb
affordability study um I just um issued
the Deb affordability study on Friday
that's going to be posted uh online
sometime today um and I don't that I
don't intend to spend a lot of time um
on this I'll be happy to spend time with
with anyone who's interested in in in
seeing the calculations behind the data
affability study but um essentially we
calculate date ratios uh for our current
fiscal year um 24 and right now is
3.8% um and we also project those ratios
using various assumptions um and and and
and um and again we we we we uh report
that in this study uh the good news is
that our current and our projected
ratios again using this assumptions are
below the medians and you can see on the
on the right column um the
medians uh from moodies and and the debt
to revenue rati which is one of is the
key debt metric uh from S&P is three
88% um again um I think and this again I
don't intend to spend too much time on
this um the the reason you see an
increase um um in 25 26 27 28 is due to
the additional bonding authorization
that was authorized um in during the 24
Corrections and slide again these are
ratings the only thing I'm going to um
mention um related to to the ratings is
the stable Outlook um this is just um
you know what this means is really the
rating agencies believe that we will
continue um the way the state has been
performing um you know over the for
foreseeable future the fact that we have
less revenues and and and you know right
now is is it's not a big concern um they
believe we're going to be able to manage
the situation and and continue to add um
again the promise to continue to add
funds to our reserves if we have to use
um funds from the reated fund to to
perhaps balance our our fiscal uh
condition um they will I'm sure they'll
be looking at you know how how soon
we're going to replace those funds and
build up those those reserves again it's
just Again part of the overall equation
um in the last page I included just key
takeaways um again you know the the idea
of the rainy day fund being a a tool for
the State uh in the event of a potential
deficit um perhaps the state may need to
um Implement some Cost Containment
measures and make um budget adjustments
this year is unclear right now um you
know um you know the governor's uh plan
right now but that could be a
possibility or a tool to be able to um
um you know finish the year uh with a
balanced budget uh something I didn't
mention before but um additional Bond
and authorizations may not impact our
debt metrics just because our our
metrics are low and below the medians
but that will definitely increase uh the
fixed cost The Debt Service and it will
impact um um our operating budget and
again um you know having diverse Revenue
um sources uh should continue to provide
adequate
um protection during fiscal challenges
economics just thinking about how when
for example if the business taxes
doesn't the business taxes don't perform
well uh but we have the meals and room
tax performing um well when you know
when one doesn't um you know is not um
performing as expected so again the idea
of having a um a
diversified
um you know basket is is important in
the state benefits uh from from that
compared to all states that rely on a
sales tax and an income tax so that
that's what I have for my presentation
I'll be happy to answer additional
questions thank you I'm I'm going to
just uh take a couple more questions
then we'll move on to the last speaker
represent ol uh thank you madam
the percentage of change seems or
percentage of
uh debt
burden seems to be relatively stable at
around 0.5% over a variety of years
using the percentage which would balance
out the inflate inflation values of the
dollar are we running in that same area
or are we running in an upward
cycle I think what I will say to the to
the rages um it it really does it really
doesn't have anything to do with
inflation except for the fact that um
you know the yields may change due to
inflation um what really um the
consistency in our debt burden really um
stems from the fact that we in in in a
this question is asked often you know we
typically recommend about 120 billion of
bonding um praid with General funds in
for every by Anum and the reason we do
that is because we like to uh continue
to recommend that amount so you can see
how the revenue how the the metrics
change over time we can we can control
our our amount of bonding but we can't
control how revenues perform and so um
that you know continue to be
conservative in the way we Bond will
allow us to maintain those metrics low
and again if the revenues the revenues
have decreased significantly over the
last few years because of the revenues
we' have collected but again if that
changes and normalizes we may see the
metrics um increase but again we're
still below the medians we're still
below what is you know 10% is considered
a war inside is something we will never
want to reach if that helps um with your
question thank you mam treasure
appreciate
it
yes yes treasure um on your last slide
you you talked about um additional
bonding authorizations may not
signicantly
impact any sense as to how much
we need to speak into your microphone
microphone right can you repeat sure and
and I believe the question relates to
how much more we can Bond yes exactly so
I I think um again I've been asked this
question U over the years uh I think we
can C we can definitely take an
additional debt we can we we have um I
can't tell you how much because it
really depends on how much that's more
Debt Service we want to pay over time
and we and I can certainly uh I could
calculate those differences but really
the impact is on the impact is on the
operating budget um the additional Debt
Service that the state will have to pay
if we wanted to bond more um that's
really the answer the state could take
on more um again the ratio is is is is
really um low you know close to uh 4%
but it's not um but again it's it's
really you know adding
a fixed cost to your parting budget
something that U you know something to
think
about
sure
no okay we are on to our last speaker of
the
it could we you're not going to have
slides right sorry if you don't have
slides we could
paper the other
challenge
oh I'm sorry I thought we had sent over
those are
extras
yeah okay I think we can get started
thank you okay good thank you um again
my name is Taylor Caswell I am the
commissioner for the Department of
Business and econom iic Affairs um we'll
move through this slide deck I think
really the role of this department has
been to actively promote both the
economy of the state but that includes
travel and tourism that includes uh
finding opportunities to provide impact
on key foundational issues to businesses
and municipalities in the state of New
Hampshire we have been now in existence
since 2017 and I think over the last
several years we have uh really
established an important role to be able
to provide these types of services to
and and do it in a series of
Partnerships with existing
municipalities Chambers of Commerce
Regional planning commissions Regional
development commissions and so on around
the state uh to advance the economy of
New Hampshire um it it says here in our
first slide we do have three divisions
our division of Economic Development we
have a division for planning and
Community Development and then we have a
separate division that handles all of
the state's tourism and Hospitality
promotional activities so I'll touch on
all of those things on slide three um
you know we often see a lot of these
rankings um come across our desk on a
regular basis the best this best that um
a lot of it is clickbait a lot of it is
just getting people to sort of run
through a bunch of pictures on a website
but this particular one I like to point
out which is the number one ranking for
economic freedom this is done by an
organization called The Frasier
Institute and they spend an enormous
amount of effort to come to this
conclusion it isn't just something that
they took a survey online these this is
based in data uh and in fact they do
this for States within the United States
but they also rank Nations and uh across
across the globe so um it is one that we
do pay attention to uh there's a lot
that we don't pay attention to um and uh
this this particular ranking we have
held now for two years in a row and for
the previous two years before that we
were number two uh Florida was number
one so we've overtaken them um
thankfully uh so I do like to point that
out um slide four on housing this is the
singal most challenging in uh issue for
our state's economy in the private
sector as we speak
we all I am sure have heard the stories
about the lack of affordable housing in
New Hampshire lack of really most
housing in general um there have been
numerous studies that have been
undertaken to sort of gauge the scale of
this issue the scale is significant uh
Bea early uh well let's just say maybe
2022 I believe we uh contracted with the
state's Regional planning commissions to
do a series of Regional Housing needs
assessments all at the same time to get
a snapshot as to where we felt that the
need is on a local level across the
state and that began the numbers that we
have now seen a steady stream of both
from the planning commissions themselves
and from New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority that put the scale at tens of
thousands of units that we need to be
able to be BR online to meet the need
and the demand that uh we definitely are
seeing out there and address the the
cost issues so one of the tools that we
brought to the table um beginning in
2022 using uh the arpa funds that were
provided was what we call the invest NH
program this was uh and you'll see um a
map on Slide Five where uh we were able
to make some fairly significant
investments in uh the issues surrounding
affordable housing uh Statewide uh the
the the the the fund in a very sort of
um uh basic overview was divided into
two um primary areas one was to help
with the ability to expand and
accelerate uh the uh access to
affordable housing with nonprofit and
for-profit developers uh that program uh
which is just wrapping up now um
invested close to $60 million into
existing projects that were just about
ready to be completed but they needed to
get over the line quickly these are
multifam units that have an
affordability component to it uh these
Investments were judged at the time as
being the highest and best use of these
funds because we really needed to see
more units come online in New Hampshire
uh as quickly as we could the remaining
part of the invest in age fund really
went directly to our municipalities to
help them uh a deal with the number of
challenges that they were seeing on
their side so we had a per unit um uh
grant program where if municipalities
were U uh permitting affordable housing
at a certain level uh there was a
$10,000 per unit grant that they became
eligible for and that was an extremely
popular program it was used for a
multitude of different purposes many
communities used that to uh invest back
in the project itself but many other
communities used that to deal with
infrastructure challenges and other
things that sometimes come when you make
those types of Investments uh we also
had programs around demolition uh that
helped communities um find uh
opportunities for new uh sites to build
affordable housing by uh clearing out
some maybe some older stock housing um
and uh and that program actually was far
more successful than I had anticipated
uh and the last piece of this I I I
point out was called our housing
opportunities program this was a grant
uh a grant program available again for
municipalities who were interested in
understanding what their options were to
address the housing crisis in their
community at the level that they felt
was appropriate for them uh this has
been an highly successful program and
one that we have been continuing to uh
work with our friends at New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority to advance but
this is uh often some I refer to this as
working with the communities of the
Willing so communities that are saying
yes yes ra we'll raise our hand and say
we we're willing to look at this we're
willing to take a look and understand
what are the options that we have as our
community to help address this issue at
a scale that meets the needs and really
the expectations of our community and
this program has been very successful
and it's given us an opportunity to have
that discussion rather than have it be
when someone shows up uh having just
purchased Farmer Brown's field in uh in
their Community uh and they show up at a
planning board meeting and say we're
going to put 75 units there and that as
you can imagine does not always go over
very well but if there's an opportunity
to talk about that way before that
developer shows up that I think is a
successful strategy and one that we have
been pursuing using the invest in ag
program I will say before I leave this
subject that in addition we have uh also
uh the legislature uh last year passed
the housing Champions program uh this is
a program where we're able to work with
municipalities to self identify as a
community that applies for and receives
a designation uh as a housing champion
and with that designation comes access
to some resources uh and Grant funds um
we just announced I think it was about
three weeks ago right before Christmas
uh about 18 communities in our first
round uh applied for and received that
that designation so uh there will be
some funds that will be available mostly
for infrastructure for those communities
uh it's about it's around about $5
million uh total that would be available
and for any of us who have anything to
do with housing you know that's probably
going to go pretty quickly um but uh
that's just another resource that we're
continuing to work with to try to
advance on this very important issue um
moving to uh I guess it's slide six um
another foundational investment that I
wanted to raise for all of you today is
the issue of high-speed internet access
this is something that has been sort of
lingering in the on the outskirts of
economic discussions around the state
for quite some time there still as of
2022 remain a number of communities that
had very limited or no access to
high-speed internet and as we saw
particularly highlighted during the
during the covid pandemic this is a
critical issue the ability to people for
people to basically execute on their
daily uh daily living uh whether it's
handing Financial matter whether it's
kids going to school or whether it's
just you know sitting down and relaxing
and watching Netflix for the evening
these are important pieces that impact
property value that impact the ability
for small towns and Main Street uh
around the state to be able to be
competitive in an international
marketplace um this was another place
where we saw some funds that came uh in
the co recovery that we quickly deployed
and got resources on the ground to
communities to help them uh achieve the
goal of 100% access to high-speed
internet and this slide and the slide
after it have two maps that begin to
show the the progress that we have made
and we are about halfway through the
process at this stage where um you know
you can see a lot a lot of white there
particularly in the North Country um in
2022 and we have begun to very seriously
eat away at that um as we have gone over
the last two years we expect to be
2027 um another important and now I'm on
slide 8 uh uh component is the the
investment of the businesses in the
state economy so Capital expenditures
since covid now we are able to track in
excess of a billion dollars of capital
expenditures by businesses either moving
here or expanding uh their operations in
New Hampshire this is a pretty
significant number and that's again only
since 2020 and and and I would say that
it is probably not the entire number
because there are a lot of business that
are expanding and coming to New
Hampshire that are just making that
happen they are not uh necessarily one
that we might have an interaction with
but of those that we do and those are
the major projects uh we are in excess
of of a billion dollars um another
component of this that I put here is
what we're calling the New Hampshire
business Gateway uh for those of you
who've been at this for a bit you'll
recall that we've been trying for years
to get a One-Stop digital platform for
the State uh and for businesses to be
able to legitimately access all state
functions from one place uh we have used
the arpa funds uh to get us to that
point this is an investment of $10
million in those funds to a long-term
solution for this issue and uh we are
quite a ways along in making this come
to fruition I expect we will see early
versions of this in the next couple of
months but this will be a tool that
we'll be able to build on over time and
it will be again a place where a small
business can find a place to add add
additional investment a startup can go
and get the the the components that they
need to start their business or we can
work with existing medium and large
scale businesses to be able to do their
business with the state again from one
place I would point out one thing I know
uh it's hard to see on this picture but
the photograph on um page eight there on
that slide deck that is taken from
inside the new life is good Warehouse in
Hudson New Hampshire this is a a half
million square foot Warehouse that uh
they invested in in last year
consolidating several other locations
including some in Massachusetts into
this facility um those shelving units
that you see in that photograph all sit
on top of little robots and their entire
inventory moves and uh around based on
uh what the needs and what the orders
are at any given moment in time it is
one of the more technologically advanced
facilities we have in New Hampshire and
uh they they do make t-shirts and mugs
and other things but that's a lot of
stuff to keep track of and this is a
signif one last thing on this if you'll
indulge me for one moment when when they
made this investment
uh to uh to put this facility in New
Hampshire that enabled them to resore
all of the operations that they had been
previously doing to uh manage their
Logistics and inventory in Peru they
closed those facilities and moved
everything back to New Hampshire due to
the ability to use technology and uh
have it all in one location um it's an
interesting fact because it does speak
to the impact of technology
and artificial intelligence as we begin
to see those types of Investments even
in things like Logistics
centers uh the next slide is uh uh on
International Trade I put this here I
won't run through all of these
statistics I put this here because this
is something I wanted to make sure
everybody's aware of since 2017 the
state has set a new record each year in
export volume and this is a a trend that
is you know not not just a blip but it
is a consistent Trend that we are seeing
one that we have latched on to and that
we have staff that work very
deliberately and closely particularly
with small and medium-sized businesses
as they continue to expand they've had
the need to find new markets and those
markets are increasingly located
internationally uh so our our staff and
our department is able to work with
those businesses to identify where their
B where their products are most
applicable or where there is a most need
and then and then work with them to be
able to access those markets and that
has been a very successful strategy and
something that I just also wanted to
point out as a revenue generating
activity um there's a quick slide here
on some of the reports and strategies I
put this here for your benefit if any of
these are such that you want to see that
we have them on our website if you would
like to have them um I can get them to
you but there over the past two years we
have made some significant investment in
understanding particularly these types
of markets because they are Central to
the work that we do
uh at the top of that list is
manufacturing and advanced manufacturing
there is tremendous opportunity right
now in New Hampshire to take advantage
of a trajectory that we have seen now
for several years in a row where there
is a significant Resurgence in the
manufacturing space in New Hampshire and
for all of you who know about the
economics of uh of different types of
sectors the resiliency of a
manufacturing uh base is one that we
would seek uh um uh treasur metp spoke
to the diversity of our economy that is
definitely the case and it is definitely
the case within the manufacturing
facility we have everything from making
pieces that go into cars to 3D printing
lungs in Manchester so there is a
diversity that exists there and there's
a number of challenges that go with that
but those are challenges that I am happy
to under to take on because they are
challenges that come from a healthy
economy the next slide speaks to some of
those uh outcomes uh I'll leave those
for you to uh to consider again if there
are issues or questions you'd like me to
discuss I'm happy to do that um so again
some of the themes that I've been
talking about here on slide 12 um uh the
recruitment of of workers continues to
be an important component of what we do
uh we we do combine that with our
tourism activity which I'll speak to
very briefly here just after this um the
collaborative uh uh Partnerships that we
have and of course job training and and
education is critical uh let's see slide
13 I I I put this photo in here this is
a this is a pretty pretty good
photograph we had a a billboard of this
in Boston last winter uh for any of you
who saw it it was right there on on
Interstate 93 it didn't say it had you
know obviously a different slogan there
but uh this generated somewhere between
I don't know about 10 and 15 calls to
our department to people who were
accusing us of using photography from
places that were not in New
Hampshire and uh of course this is very
much in New Hampshire and it is
something uh it's Tuckerman Ravine in at
Mount Washington uh and uh but it had uh
the impact that we were seeking I think
as it related to
that yes um so uh I put this here
visitor spending you'll see that we have
obviously seen a very significant jump
over the last couple of years and it has
been a trend that has maintained since
2020 since covid um I would point out
that this visitor spending level has
resulted in revenues that have increased
under the meals and rentals tax now
significantly each year now we are over
$300 million in Revenue uh since the
covid pandemic and we've maintained that
level uh consistently over the last four
years
years here's a slide that shows the
visitation numbers uh obviously a
similar
Trend uh slide 16 I put this here to
give you sort of an idea of the type of
product that we do put out there um uh
these are whether they're Billboards
mostly digital ads the ones that I would
point to you are the ones in the Middle
where it says enter your text here this
is a new product that we've developed
that we've made available to businesses
around the state to be able to take
templates like this use creative content
photography video that we've generated
uh and and and apply it as they see fit
whether if they're recruiting a new
Workforce or whether they want to
upgrade their website or whe they want
to do a lot of small businesses have
taken us up on this and it's all free
and available on our website so
something again there where we're
providing some value to our businesses
and making the marketing look very
similar which is obviously of value to
those of you who've been in the
marketing space so I think my last slide
here is really reiterating some of the
issues that I've talked about uh today
the one that I have not touched on that
I do think uh is something we need to be
looking at from an economic perspective
is the issue of child care um as we
continue to see uh very positive Trends
in terms of uh population growth and
particularly in uh working age
population growth uh in uh not just our
urban areas but in rural areas around
the state it is a trend that we are
seeing uh those those are typically
young families and those are young
families that are in many cases in need
of some type of child care to be able to
uh participate in our Workforce and to
uh really experience the full uh uh the
full capabilities of our economy so I
put that there uh because it is
something that we consider as important
um almost as important as as the housing
issue as we as we move forward so so
that is my very brief and and quick
overview of a lot of the economic issues
uh Mr chairman and happy to take any
questions thank you that was very
helpful um we have a lot of questions
why don't we just start here and work
this way representative ORS thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
so approximately if you know off top of
your what is your budget yearly budget
so uh we have a a General Revenue budget
about $16 million we have Federal
funding that is a little less than that
about 15 million oh what
and so uh how much do you attribute the
money you you take the money you're
spending to run your department so on
and so forth how much additional Revenue
do you think you provide to the state
can you quantify that I can tell you
that uh we have done studies on that as
it relates to the tourism component
which of that roughly what did I say 15
or 16 million in state cost uh roughly
uh 10 to 11 million of that is
specifically for our work in tourism
marketing that our current return on
investment statistic is
$17 in return for every dollar that we
invest in marketing okay excellent
that's a pretty good return I remember I
think was state in New York I love New
York they canceled their program and
they lost Untold Millions by cancelling
that program so good very good thank you
yes we were happy to receive them here
Hampshire coming around this way who uh
yes represent berer thank you Mr chair
uh I'm having a little yeah let me try
to slide over here
uh New Hampshire has the lowest State
support for public education in the
country and the second highest college
instate tuition in the country we've had
the highest increase in the number of
unhoused people in the entire
country my constituents are telling me
that they are quitting their jobs
because they can't afford the cost of
child care and they can't get health
care appointments because there aren't
sufficient providers so looking back on
the statement about New Hampshire is
ranked number one for economic freedom
I'm trying to figure out what that means
can you please help me yes ma'am so I
think obviously those issues that you
rais are really critical to our
employers and obviously to our
communities but I would say at the same
time these are issues that are
reflective of the growth of our economy
since Co we have seen some significant
uh growth and and and there has been
some significant investment as I pointed
out in expansion and in new Recruitment
and that requires uh uh housing for for
employees that requires uh new Access to
Health Care Child Care all the things
that you're mentioning and what that has
done is put strain on existing systems
that are in place so I think as we
continue to see growth in the economy
that comes with other challenges uh
along the way so there are many ways
that that can be addressed and I think
that those are the issues that are going
to be Central to the discussions uh of
the budget over the next couple of
months thank you yes representative
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
commissioner for taking my question
several years ago uh this committee was
uh instrumental in helping Dean Cayman
uh move forward with army project and I
would like to know if we have any
information
on that project and that bill that we
passed and what excuse me what return
yeah uh we may have had you may not have
an answer for that specifically but I'd
like to yes inv I I would love to uh get
that information for you because I'd
like to know the answer to that myself I
I I have heard from uh the parties that
use those funds that has been extremely
useful but let me get some information
for you and the committee and we'll get
that back to
you R me thank you I just wanted to ask
where we can find the reports that
you're talking about in there so we can
get more detail yes ma'am they are on
our website which is NH economy.com
if you would like you can email me at
taylor. well nh.gov and I will send them
to you directly if you'd rather not have
to search for them on our website
it thank
you um or or send it to Gen 4 and she
can distribute it to the committee
whichever's easier yeah that Jen gets a
lot of emails from me so sounds good uh
did you have a question represent Erie
did you have a question okay moving this
Rosenwald do you have ecomic freed
I would say I I I hadn't fully examined
any partisan component to that to that
ranking and uh I don't have like an
alternative economic ranking to their to
theirs they they sort of own that space
they have for some years and it it's an
international organization I can't I I
can't speak to the politics of a
Canadian libertarian but those uh their
statistics I think are not necessarily
okay
invest and I know we made a change in
yeah what percent of those UNS are
five so I don't I don't it's it's a it's
a high majority that are affordable of
the 5,000 I don't have that number stuck
in my head right now but let me get that
for you Senator um but you are correct
the uh the the the funds that were used
under the $60 million component of
invest NH were for five years right the
anything that we're doing under housing
Champions or subsequent invest inh
programs that are funded by the state
are required to be at 10 years so that
difference okay well I can take one more
question yes represent
Opel uh thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you commissioner for taking my
question I and I I realize this is
difficult but but part of this
committee's mission is to is to look
into the future um and and provide
Finance committees with with information
I'm wondering at this point um in your
agency um if you've had an opportunity
to begin to assess the impact if the
federal government does indeed go
forward with pretty significant tariff
program what impact that might have both
on um the the economic impact in New
Hampshire both the businesses that are
obviously exporting as you highlighted
um and the possibility of retaliatory
tariffs uh from EU for example um and
just generally on the on the economic
picture what whether you've had an
opportunity to assess it or if you
haven't um what information you'll be
providing to us later on we have done uh
some early assessment on that and it's
based on historic uh activity in this
area and and in the long term uh tariffs
at that level are significantly
detrimental to our economy uh
those are uh we depend very heavily on
the crossborder traffic with Canada
particularly they are by far our largest
trading partner uh we obviously sit
right on the border uh a lot of the
Investments that I mentioned the billion
dollars since 2020 uh I would say a good
portion of that is Investments that have
been made by the Canadians in in New
Hampshire um I I think one Dynamic that
we are seeing right now is a is a uptick
in a lot of activity around those
products that um would be Pro
potentially uh impacted by a tariff so
there's a bump that we see right now in
terms of that activity but if this goes
on for a long period of time that could
be a challenge um I would say uh the
experience we had under covid where we
closed the border is extremely
instructive that that did not assist
with the recovery and then once the
Border reopened uh we saw significant
benefit at that point at that time we
were also dealing with a tourism benefit
because people themselves couldn't get
over the Border um but uh the movement
of of goods and services uh between New
Hampshire and particularly Canada are
significant thank you commissioner
Caswell that's has been very informative
thank you
everyone all right um as you can see
from the program the next speaker is at
1: p.m. so that leaves us about uh 43
minutes for lunch um um so we will
1:00
e
um we'll get on to our next uh speaker
which is Dr Kenneth
and i' I've been told that um for people
watching online they're not able to hear
uh senators
or a representative or whoever who is
not at a microphone so what I would ask
uh you to do Dr Johnson is if someone
from this inner table that doesn't have
a microphone asks you a question if you
could just restate the question so
online people
okay I guess everyone is mostly settled
so we will start you can start by
I'm Ken Johnson I'm a demographer and
professor of Sociology at the University
of New Hampshire and uh I appreciate
being invited to talk to this
group I think demographic Trends in the
state are important so I'm glad to have
an opportunity to summarize them for you
I'd just like to acknowledge the people
who have funded my
research uh that you're hearing about
today you can see it's a broad way of
array of places and if somebody's
interested in that afterwards I can tell
you how NASA ended up funding a
demographer but anyway so New
Hampshire's popultion growth Trends have
slowed in recent decades but in the
short term that is in the last few years
migration and population growth in the
state have
increased so when I talk about
demographic change and I'm not I'm not
trying to make this demography 101 but
it is important to recognize populations
change in a variety of different ways
they can change by natural change which
is the difference between births and
deaths and then Mig my migration is the
other driving force of population change
and it's always a combination of in
migrants and out migrants and that's a
point I want to make to you later on in
some of my talk I'll talk about two
different kinds of migration domestic
migration which is people moving to New
Hampshire from other us destinations and
then immigration which is people moving
to New Hampshire from another country
directly from another
country so this is just a
long-term or at least decadal trend for
uh New England and you can see that New
Hampshire is among the fastest growing
States in New Hampshire or in New
England uh and most of its growth comes
as you'll note here from the
migration natural change that is the
difference between ver and deaths which
used to fuel a lot of growth in New
Hampshire fuels much less of it
now these are the most recent data
available released by the Census Bureau
less than a month ago and they show the
M patterns of population change between
2020 and
2024 and here you can see a more
detailed reflection of recent
demographic Trends so New Hampshire's
population grew between 20 and
2024 all of the growth all of the growth
came from migration there were more
deaths than births in New Hampshire
between 2020 and 2024 now part of that's
because of the pandemic but New
Hampshire already had more deaths than
births what demographers call Natural
decrease before the pandemic began
so again if New Hampshire's population's
going to grow the growth is going to
come from migration and you can see in
these data that between 2020 and 2024
most of the growth in New Hampshire came
from domestic migration from people
moving to New Hampshire from other us
destinations there's also a modest
amount of immigration but if you look at
New Hampshire for example in comparison
to Massachusetts which is right next to
it on this graphic you can see that
Massachusetts had domestic migration
loss more people left Massachusetts than
came to it and its population grew
primarily because of immigration and so
you can see the contrast in the
different states about how population
change came to
be this is just po just so you can see a
map this is population change by county
for New England and New York uh between
2020 and
2023 and you can see that all of New
Hampshire's counties grew during that
period these are the very long-term
population change trends for New
Hampshire from the 1970s forward and you
can see the balance between net
migration and natural increase changes
net migration fueled most of the growth
in New Hampshire through most of this
period but natural increase was also an
important driving force but as you get
to 2010 to 2020 you can see that natural
increase diminishes to almost nothing
and all of almost all the growth is
fueled by
migration these then are more detailed
data showing you the early part of the
201 to 2020 decade and the later part
this is when the between 2010 and 2015
the recession was still affecting New
Hampshire and it slowed domestic
migration to the to the state as we get
into the later part of the decade this
is when burth began to not be as
numerous as deaths and the population
began to decline through natural decline
that was offset by a combination of
domestic and immigration and then
between 20 and 2024
the natural decrease increased again
partially because of covid and the
domestic migration into New Hampshire
accelerated immigration also continued
now part of this we think is because of
Co itself that is States like New
Hampshire tended to receive an influx of
of domestic migrants During the period
of covid whereas States like
Massachusetts particularly the urban
core of Massachusetts experienc
population out
migration uh similar Trends exist in
other parts of uh New England especially
Northern New England and also in other
parts of the country
where places with big Urban cores had
domestic
outmigration at the same time that
immigration was diminishing because of
the
pandemic and then States like New
Hampshire gained migrants during this
period now a big question as we go into
the future is whether that domestic
migration will be sustained or whether
it will slow down the most recent data
I've seen that it isn't on these slides
suggests that migration to New Hampshire
may be slowing in the last year or
so this is the this is burs and deaths
just so you can see the
natural part of the change in New
Hampshire's population reaching all the
way back to 1970 and you can see the
birds traditionally had exceeded deaths
by a substantial number number but
starting in about
2018 deaths began to in to be more
frequent than burst in the state so this
is before the pandemic hit and then the
pandemic hit and the gap between burst
and Des increased you can see that it's
fallen off slightly in the last year the
newest CDC data which isn't complete yet
suggests that it's slowed that the gap
between birs and deaths probably
narrowed a little bit more in the last
few months ons now New Hampshire has
natural decrease more deaths and births
because it has an older
population because it has fewer women of
childbearing age and because the
fertility rates among women in New
Hampshire are lower than they are
elsewhere so the combination of those
things an older population fewer women
of childbearing age lower birth rates
among women of childbearing age produces
this combination of more deaths and
Bros now this is an important slide and
and if you take one thing away from my
talk this would be one of the things I'd
want you to take away a lot of what I've
been talking about is net migration
that's the difference between the inflow
and the outflow of people into the state
so what this graphic does is to break
down those patterns so that you can see
each part of them so on the left we have
natural change the difference between
births and deaths and you can see that
between 2018 and 2022 there were about
60,000 births in New Hampshire but
68,000 deaths so there's that natural
loss of
7,000 but the numbers I really want you
to look at are the next set that is for
domestic
migration so New Hampshire had a net
change through domestic migration of
about 36,000 people between 2018 and
2022 and you might say well gee out of a
population of 1.4 million 36,000 isn't
very many but the thing I want you to
see here is that that change of 36,000
came because 260,000 people moved into
New Hampshire from other us destinations
and 224,000
left it's now in a state of 1.4 million
you're talking about a turnover of the
population of almost 500,000
so in a sense the people are in New many
of the people who are in New Hampshire
now weren't here five or 10 years ago
and many people who were here aren't
here anymore so when you think about New
Hampshire's population it has one of the
highest turnover rates in the United
States there's
more in andout flows from New Hampshire
than from many other
states and then you can see immigration
as well which is New Hampshire has a
very modest immigration
generally uh 13 about 14,000 moved in
immigrants came directly to New
Hampshire now somebody if a person came
to Massachusetts from Mexico and then
later move from Mex from new Hamp from
Massachusetts to New Hampshire that's
considered a domestic migrant so just to
keep that distinction clear these are
people moving directly to New Hampshire
part of
that Trend that we were talking about is
reflected in this graphic this graphic
shows that the majority of the people
living in New Hampshire were born
somewhere else how many of you were born
Hampshire not very many right only about
40% of the people in New Hampshire were
born in the
state only four states have a smaller
proportion of their population born in
the state so New Hampshire much more
than many other states is a state where
people have come from somewhere else
some came a long time ago someone CA
some came fairly
recently but it's not a state that has
most of the people living in it having
been born
here and you can see in that sense that
it's different than New England and
different than the United States both of
which tend to have roughly 60% of the
people people living in the state having
been born
there so when you think about New
Hampshire recognize it as a state where
population this is where domestic
migrants people moving in the United
States come from and go to now it's
probably no surprise to you that the
biggest source of migrants to New
Hampshire is Massachusetts in fact about
25% of the population of New Hampshire
was born in Massachusetts
so you can see the inflow of people to
New Hampshire on the left and then where
people leave New Hampshire to go to on
the right and there you can see that
places like the South are better are
much more likely to receive out migrants
from New Hampshire than inmigrants
coming from them to New
Hampshire and again this emphasizes the
point this is in one year 50,000 in
migrants and 44,000 out migrants that
again is that that big turnover that
produces a change of 6,000 and also
there was probably about 5,000
immigrants coming to New Hampshire
during that period as
well now this is some really new data
we're actually going to release this
research later this week but it was so
striking that I wanted you to see it not
just people flow between places but
money flows between places as well well
and so this is Internal Revenue Service
data and it shows between 2020 and 2022
so the three years of the
pandemic this is the annual flow of
income to and from New Hampshire because
of
migration so the orange bar shows look
at Massachusetts for example the orange
bar shows
that immigrants from New Hampshire
people who move here in an annual on an
in a per in the in one year so these are
annual numbers even though they're for
three
years they had income of about 1.4
billion the people who left New
Hampshire for Massachusetts had an a net
income or gross income of about
$487
million so in that migration Exchange in
in a in a year New Hampshire gained
about $952 million of income from that m
ation exchange with New Hampshire or
with Massachusetts now you can see the
trends with other places as well clearly
when you look at the South for example
more money flows out of New Hampshire to
the South than comes into New Hampshire
from the South but again appreciate it
it's not just people that are moving
it's income as well this is uh this
summarizes the whole period one key
point is that the income flow into New
Hampshire from Massachusetts increased
dramatically during the recession or
during the
pandemic so before the pandemic the net
gain over three years was 1.3 mil3
billion during the pandemic it went up
to $2.8 billion do in three years so
quite a contrast now a big question is
what's going to happen in the future if
the migration from New Hampshire from
Massachusetts to New Hampshire slows
down it's likely that the income stream
will as well
but again it's not just people who are
moving this is actual people moving and
so you can see that the the number of
migrants to New Hampshire from
Massachusetts increased as well but
incomes increased a lot more which would
suggest that relatively High income
households tended to move from
Massachusetts to New Hampshire now
there's anecdotal evidence that this has
gone on not just in New Hampshire but in
other parts of the country as well where
there are large recreational areas that
people who had more flexibility in their
jobs May well have moved from one place
to another uh to more pleasant or more
recreationally oriented areas during the
pandemic um you've all heard this I I
assume you've heard the stories if you
haven't that it was almost impossible to
buy housing in places like Lake wiip in
is that going to slow down and we
honestly just don't know
yet so education is another resource
that comes to New Hampshire from
migration these data show the uh
educational attainment levels of
different groups within New Hampshire so
for example if you look at college
graduates a little bit over or a little
bit under 20% of New
Hampshire born residents over the age of
25 have a college a bachelor's degree
and contrast the migrants into the state
and the immigrants tend to have higher
education levels both at the you can see
it at the college degree level and also
at the graduate degree level so New
Hampshire receives people it receives
income and it re it receives skilled and
educated people in the migration
patterns that are going on that's one of
the reasons why I think migration is
very important to the state these are
age specific migration patterns over the
last three decades they show us what the
age structure of the people coming to
and leaving the state are and you can
see that New Hampshire tends to gain
people in their 30s and 40s that's the
in the middle of the graph and each of
those bars the blue gray and and red are
showing you the last three decades so
New Hampshire tends to gain people in
their working ages from 30 to 50 and it
you can see the influx of children too
many of those children are coming with
them in contrast New Hampshire in some
decades has experienced a loss of people
in their 20s uh between 20 and 10 and
20120 the loss was
minimal uh but in the 20 2000 to20
period the loss was somewhat larger so
if New Hampshire's going to lose people
it loses people in their 20s but
relative modest shares of that
population it gains people in their
working ages and it gains children it
has a modest inflow of older adults as
well so many states would give anything
to have the migration profile that New
Hampshire does that that it re they
receive working age population
especially as we've seen from the
earlier slides well-educated
uh people with significant incomes
migrating into the
state these are the most recent
migration data they're not quite as good
as the data I just showed you but you
can see that the trends are similar that
there's an influx of people in their 30s
and
40s uh and an influx of children with
them and and then modest Flows at other
ages into or out of the state but almost
oldest this just to give you some idea
yeah
oh yeah I'm sorry you that's I put that
in at the last minute so mostly to
confuse you but it's not right sorry I
just couldn't bear not to
have I couldn't bear not to have the
latest data in there yeah see I'm glad
you were paying
attention Okay this graphic just shows
you how many babies were born in New
Hampshire that's the blue bar and then
how many children began the first first
grade six years later and you can see I
mean this data these data go back quite
a ways but notice that in every year
more kids begin the first grade than
were born in New Hampshire six years
earlier this is more evidence of that
influx of working age people with
children right because they don't just
bring the children with them they bring
now as you all know demographic change
varies across New
Hampshire this is population change from
2010 to
2020 and then from 2020 to 2023 which is
the newest data we have at the at this
level of geography and you can see that
the grow more of the growth occurs in
the South particularly in the southeast
part of the state than
elsewhere and you can see that the
growth was more widespread between 2020
and 2023 than it had been in the 2010s
so so far in this decade the un uh New
Hampshire has received more population
growth than it did later and you can see
that the highest growth rates continue
to be mostly in the southern part of the
state or in the recreational areas in
the middle part of the state but even in
the northern part of the state which had
widespread population loss in the last
decade there have been population gains
so uh this is just to underscore the
fact that population is is changing in
New Hampshire that it's uneven some
places are gaining population some
places are losing population but in
general the state has done better in the
first three years of this decade than it
did in the 2010 to 2020
period this is just uh the growth rate
or the population gains in each of New
England New Hampshire's 10 counties
be for the 2010 to 2020 period in blue
and in the 2020 to 2023 period in red
and you can see that for most of the
counties they gained more population
recently than they did earlier so again
The Point again is that the the
population growth rates vary across the
everywhere this is just for the most
recent data and it shows population
change
for each of the counties broken down by
how the population grew or declined
you'll notice first that only Hillsboro
County had more births than deaths all
the other nine counties of the state had
more people dying than be born during
the period so but it all the all the
counties in the state gained population
and that population gain was almost
entirely due to migration so again this
just underscores how important migration
I I picked out four different kinds of
counties in New Hampshire so you could
see the patterns compared to one another
on the left is Carol County which of
course is a recreational County in the
middle of the state its growth is
entirely fueled by migration it has the
highest growth in the in the
state um it's very common for
recreational counties like Carol to gain
migrants from other places there are
about 300 counties like Caroll County in
the United States and they have all
almost all their growth is fueled by
migration from people moving to them
partially it's PE older people moving to
them to Second homes or to enjoy the
recreational amenities of the area but
other people are coming to staff the
hospitals build the
Cottages fix the roads all the other
things that have to be done in a in a
county like that Rockingham County is a
is a considered part of the Boston
metropolitan area so it's in many ways
the outermost edge of the Boston suburbs
or exurban I'm not sure that they would
be happy to be referred to as suburbs of
Boston but you can see that the pattern
of change there is the growth is slower
but migration is fueling much of it
there was a little bit of natural
increase 2010 to 2020 but not during the
2020 to 2023 period Hillsboro County you
can see also is the only County that had
population increase from natural
increase in both periods its growth rate
actually slowed between 2020 and 2023
compared to earlier because migration to
the area diminished and then Kos
County um experienced a lot of natural
decrease in each of the two de
periods in 2010 to 2020 there was very
modest immigra uh domestic migration but
it wasn't enough to offset that natural
decline between 2020 and 2023 migration
increased to the county and it was
enough to offset the very substantial
increase in uh deaths over
births so four different counties within
the same state each with a quite a
different kind of demographic change
path
you all have heard that New Hampshire is
aging
rapidly this is population excuse me are
you willing to take questions during the
rosenal about birth are you talking
about where the baby is born or where
the baby was right place of birth is
measured in these data by the residents
of the
mother I mean we have problems with that
because when you get down to close to
the Massachusetts border many children
are born in Mass uh New Hampshire
children are born in Massachusetts but
they're counted in the place where they
live okay good question uh we go one
more representative elme yes is there
any way we could see these slides online
in
color yes I mean if we can arrange for
we can arrange for it
than okay I know I'm throwing a lot of
data at you your eyes don't look quite
as glazed over as my undergraduates
would but I apologize for but I mean
there this is a complicated story and I
want you to see as much of the Nuance of
it as you can this is just population
change in New Hampshire and I marked two
cohorts uh what birth cohorts these are
for example the one that's in blue at
the top that's the cohort that was born
between 1950 and 59 so that's the heart
of the baby boom a few of us are in that
cohort and I'm just tracing it through
the three decades so you can see that
cohort the big blue bar in their 40s
that was the baby boom cohort in the
1990s by the 2000 to 2010 period they're
the Red Bar they've shifted over 10
years in age and now
uh through in 2020 they're that light
green bar that you can see in their 60s
so that's the progression of the cohort
through the 30 years the smaller cohort
born in 70 to 79 you can see it moving
through uh on the bottom as well so it
starts in its 20s and then shifts upward
so bottom line is that the cohorts that
have children in them are getting
smaller while the cohort hearts that
have older adults in them are getting
bigger through this progression through
the age
structure this is a population pyramid
this shows the population of New
Hampshire in
1990 the blue is the is men the red is
women and each of those bars represents
a 5-year period so right at the very
bottom are the babies that were just
born between 1986 and
1990 and the baby boom generation the
one born
you can see them in their 30s were born
between 56 and 60 so you can see that
the at that time New Hampshire had a
very large working age
adults that bar is that pyramid is on
the left on the right is the population
of New Hampshire in
2020 so you can see the upward shift of
the population so that there are fewer
children at the bottom and that big
bulge of the baby boom is now in their
60s and 70s this is a close this is just
so the population aging that's occurring
in New Hampshire is what what
demographers would call Aging in place
it's not that a huge number of older
adults are moving to New Hampshire
increasing the older population the way
they would for example in
Florida this population is Aging in
place and you can see that the cohorts
who are moving into the older age groups
are much larger than the cohorts that
were older than them so for example
people who were 60 to 69 in two 2020
there were 218,000 of them the cohort
ahead of them has only
159,000 now partially that's because
mortality has diminished the size of
that cohort but that baby boom cohort is
just bigger and so as though and the
cohort right behind it who were 50 59
and 2020 are also quite substantial so
it's those big cohorts moving into older
ages that's producing the silver tsunami
as it's called in contrast you can see
that the younger
population uh are smaller and they're
growing only
slowly the distribution of age and of
age in New Hampshire is also an
important point that is just like
there's diversity and population change
in New hampsh
there's also diversity and age
distributions so the graph on the left
is showing you what percentage of the
population in each of these areas is
under the age of
18 and the dot map on the right is
showing you actually how many people
that is and so you can see that in the
southern part of the state not only is a
larger proportion of the population
in contrast in the north the population
has fewer young people and also there
are just fewer people there as well so I
mean imagine the implications this has
for school systems and
uh operations or institutions that are
CH that are child-based like maternity
WS this is the working age population 18
again you can see that the distrib What
proportion of the populations in those
age groups varies quite a bit with a
larger proportion of the population in
the southern part of the state
especially in the Southeast being of
working age and also in the right hand
map you can see that just in terms of
the number of people who are in those
groups it's much more concentrated in
the southern part of the state of course
that's where most of the people are this
is the older part of the population you
may see the biggest contrasts here large
proportions of the population in the
north are
older compared to in the
South they
represent a modest share of the
population most of the older people are
still concentrated in the southern part
of the state just because that's where
most of the population is so again the
point I'm trying to make to you is that
there's dramatic diversity even within
this small state that there are places
that are growing rapidly that have to
cope with growth and new schools and
things like that and then there are
other parts of the state which have
their populations either stable or
diminishing and have to deal with all
the issues that are involved in dealing
with the Contracting population such as
closing schools combining school
districts which if you want to upset a
community just talk about combining
you hear a lot about New Hampshire's
population New Hampshire's percentage of
population over the age of
65 is eth in the United States there are
you can see the states above it Maine
has the oldest population in terms of
percentage over 65 the median age in New
Hampshire is higher it's the second
oldest in terms of median age so even in
terms of how we measure age New
Hampshire's either
in the old one of the oldest States or
age there's a lot of different kinds of
diversity in New Hampshire there's
racial and ethnic diversity this is how
this is the diversity of the United
States and this is the probabil the the
graphic is showing the chances that two
people who randomly meet in the county
what are the chances there are from the
same or from a different racial or
ethnic group so the yellows and the
oranges are places where the population
is the most diverse the blues especially
the dark Blues are the places where the
population is the least diverse where if
you run into somebody else in your
county they're almost certainly going to
be the same as
you this is a closeup just of New
England so that you can see the variety
in uh diversities across New England
with Massachusetts being much more
diverse than any of the Northern New
England
states 12.8% of New Hampshire's
population was minority and by minority
non-hispanic 12% 12.8% it's a little
higher now it's probably 13 and a half%
I would
guess all of the growth in New
Hampshire's population that was from the
12.8% that are minority the minor
population in New Hampshire grew between
2010 and 2020 the white population
didn't
grow the child population in New
Hampshire is the most diverse part of
the population this is true across the
United States the most diverse
population in the United States are the
babies that were born this year the
least diverse are the are the oldest
parts of the population and you can see
that's true in New Hampshire 20% of the
children in New Hampshire in 2020 we're
minority compared to 11% of the adult
population so institutions that deal
with children are dealing with diversity
first it will come later to other parts
population this is change showing you
change in the size of the population
between 2010 and
2023 the youth population the white
child population diminish during that
period while the minority child
population increased modestly the adult
working age population that was white
diminished during that period that loss
was upset offset by an increase in the
minority population in the working ages
and then the older population in New
Hampshire the growth was almost
overwhelmingly non-hispanic white and
again that's that Aging in place which
is moving those people up the age
structure Through Time
so again the population of New Hampshire
although it's not one of the most
diverse in the country it is becoming
more diverse and the diversity is coming
from youngest to
oldest this is the distribution of the
population the minority population in
New Hampshire you can see large parts of
New Hampshire have virtually no
minorities in them or less than 10% that
would be the greens but there are areas
that are much more diverse again
underscoring the fact that
diversity varies in the state along a
lot of different
dimensions here again is the child and
the adult population in New Hampshire
the diversity by Geographic areas and
you can see that it's the child
population that is more
diverse across the state whether you're
talking about in the northern part of
the state in the
Southeast it's always the child
population that's more diverse
underscoring that change that's coming
in the
state this is the mash Manchester
Corridor in other words right up that
the interstate between Manchester and
nashaa this is how diverse the
population is in those areas on the left
is the total population so there are
areas in Manchester that are more than
40% minority and then the child
population's on the right and you can
see how much more widespread diversity
is in that Urban
Corridor than it is elsewhere in the
state so within the state and within sub
areas of the state there's a a range of
diversity uh that has lots of
implications for lots of different
agencies but that's not the only way as
the state is diverse there's a lot of
other diversity in the state this is
income and education diversity
in the state these data are from the
time of the
census uh I showed you the more recent
data which shows a slightly higher
proportion of the population having
bachelor's degrees or more and higher
incomes in the state but the patterns
are the same that is there are part
parts of the state which have extremely
high income distributions and well
educated populations and other parts
that don't so
diversity ranges AC Ross a variety of
different places this is poverty New
Hampshire is fortunate in having either
the lowest or the next to the lowest
poverty rate in the United
States only
7.2% of the population currently is in
poverty and only 7.8% of the children
that's extremely low numbers
but that varies across the state there
are places in the state where a
substantial part of the population or a
significant part is in poverty so just
like there's diversity and population
change and age structures and race
there's diversity along uh poverty lines
these are gen these are just differences
in college education levels and high
school education Levels by race so you
can see that there's diversity there as
well notice the extremely high level of
college degrees or more among the Asian
this is just income by race so that you
can see that there's variability and
income across the state just like
continuums so the blue bars are the
lowest under under $50,000 of household
income or family income and the yellow
bars are over $150,000 a year of family
income so you can see the variation
there as well so again these things vary
along geography they vary by race and
ethnicity this is poverty although again
New Hampshire is blessed with extremely
low poverty levels they do vary by
racial and ethnic group across the state
just like they do
geographically these data are all from
around the time of the census I just
added and you don't have this slide
again I I don't think do you no okay so
this is just the newest data it shows
much the same story
the first bar the blue bar is percent
with their bachelor's degrees or more
the second bar is the household income
distributions what percentage of the
households earn over
$100,000 and then the third bar is
poverty and you can see the story here
is pretty much the same as it was in the
graphics you have it's just that this is
the newest data that's
available so again even in this small
state there's a great deal of
variability along a lot of dimensions in
what's happening in New Hampshire I know
you're well aware of that but it's one
thing to know it from seeing it it's
another thing to see all the data so I
hope that's helpful to
you one of the things we've done a lot
of work on recently is this question
since migration is so important to New
Hampshire we've done quite a bit of
research on why do people move to New
Hampshire or why do they stay in New
Hampshire because a lot of the attention
seems to be on attracting people to New
Hampshire or and it's not just New
Hampshire all the states would be
focused on this but the other part of it
is retention of people if people stay in
New
Hampshire they also continue to
contribute to the state it's not just
attracting new people it's holding on to
the people that you have and so we've
been we asked a variety of questions
using the unh's granite state poll to
survey thousands of people in two time
period about
this so we asked them in their own words
it's this is not a check box where you
go in and check a box but we asked them
what the three biggest reasons were for
them to either have moved to New
Hampshire if they moved relatively
recently or to stay in New Hampshire and
then we coded all of that data into
categories so this is not the kind of
standard survey where you are asked to
check three things we asked them they
told us in their own words and we
translated it all which is an arduous
undertaking so what are the top reasons
the blue bar is for recent migrants the
people who've come to New Hampshire in
the last few years why did they
come and the orange bar is for people
who've lived in New Hampshire for at
least 10 years why are they still here
what is it that that makes them stay in
New Hampshire and you can see how
important family is
to both of
them and family means different things
to people at different ages for older
adults it might be that they want to be
close to their grandchildren so if their
fames in the Boston metropolitan area
and they want to be close to them they
can stay in New Hampshire and be close
to them or if their kids are in New
Hampshire and their grandchildren they
can move to New Hampshire and be near
them so that's what family means for
older adult for younger adults it might
mean I wanted to be back close to my mom
and dad so they could help with the
children or so they could see the
children or so that we could be back
with them natural environment I mean
pretty much speaks for itself the beauty
of New Hampshire the Lakes the mountains
lots of people talked about how
attractive that was to them both among
those who live here already and among
people who migrate here Quality of Life
by quality of life people meant things
like I feel comfortable with my
neighbors I feel safe in my neighborhood
I like the rural kind of feel of the
place obviously employment would have
been more important to the recent
migrants if people are coming to New
Hampshire one reason they may be coming
is because of employment
opportunities people mention taxes
although it's certainly not high on the
list culture and lifestyle again they
like the kind of rural Vibe the kind of
laidback style of New Hampshire and then
some people talk the about the economy
in general so again a lot of different
reasons why
people either stay here or come here and
one of the the other thing we found was
that people usually don't come or stay
for one reason there's usually multiple
reasons why they
come right so they might want to be
close to their family but they also love
the natural environment or or they find
the economic opportunities here
attractive but it also means it's a good
social place to live it's a good place
to raise a family
so I mean if I would like you to take
away from this that people move and stay
in New Hampshire for a variety of
reasons and again you can see what they
are economics physical Place
family so as you're thinking about New
Hampshire's future and about the
importance of my migration recognize
that it's
both keeping people in New Hampshire and
attracting people to New Hampshire so
just to summarize that migration is
important to New
Hampshire they move for multiple
reasons when you think about
policies think about those that might
attract families or hold on to families
like quality of
Education things that preserve the
state's natural beauty that enhance its
quality of life and that enhance its
employment opportunities all of those
are important and again people don't
stay or leave for a single reason they
it's a matrix of reasons that they do so
just to conclude my
talk population growth in New Hampshire
has slowed in the long term but it's
it's picked up
recently migrations fueled all the
recent growth in New Hampshire enough to
offset the excess of debt over
birth demographic change is uneven
across the state some parts of the state
are growing rapidly other parts of the
state are either declining or not
growing very much at all the state
is very much non-hispanic white but the
diversity of the population's increasing
and especially among young people in the
aging just couple more points migration
I I don't want to overemphasize
migration but it demographically it's
really bit important to the state it's a
important source of human capital it
brings people it brings skills it brings
education and that's not just attracting
people but holding on to the people that
you
have it's not a very diverse state but
it's becoming more diverse people have
to think about that as they plan for the
future it's uneven and the age of the
concern um I think that the the older
population is going to continue to grow
in New
Hampshire
um so it's just one thing that has to be
born in mind along with all the other
issues that you face every day as you
try and do its best for the state thank
you very much thank you um do we have
any questions for Dr Johnson
yes represent
Bolton
time so there are a couple of um first
of all it's a lot of data yeah I know
I'm sorry just a couple of um things
that I I always believed but I guess
they probably shouldn't I thought there
were two towns in New Hampshire that are
actually getting younger but not like
overly so that's Bethlehem and
Littleton it may be I don't I well
looking at your your data it certainly
doesn't look that way so uh I'm not sure
if that's bragging rights or not um you
send me an email I can look and find out
for sure well I probably should sign up
for one of your classes actually but um
I also have a question about like we
hear that University
system is not that well funded it hadn't
been for some some time and the fact
that they can't offer incentives to get
like New Hampshire kids to enroll
because it's cheaper going out of state
or and there were two rationals of why
it' be important to keep the New
Hampshire kids here because well first
of all uh our state is aging second of
all we need them to land where there's
employment and a good good environment
to raise their kids and it also looks
like if we we basically are going to be
dependent upon you know like immigrants
from Massachusetts or something which
are pretty much providing Our Hope and
Dreams by moving into our state having
kids and so I'm I'm just kind of like uh
concerned that a solution Le the New
Hampshire problem would be fund the
univers system with more money and get
um good employment
opportunities
and
um so I think that's part of that whole
population retention issue that that so
much attention has been paid to
attracting people that not enough has
been paid to holding on to the people
the good people we already have in the
state so anything that would increase
least the likelihood that people would
be staying is is important um certainly
the university system is a valuable
resource to the state
um I spent a lot of my I mean I grew up
in
Michigan when I went to college I didn't
even think about it anywhere other than
the state universities in Michigan um
because they were less expensive but
also because I'd been there I'd seen
them I knew what they were like um I
think that's important here in New
Hampshire too that that that kids feel
that they can go I mean the University
of New Hampshire is an exceptionally
good school actually um sometimes people
locally don't appreciate that but it is
a good school certainly it would be
you'd get a fine education there it
would be wonderful if more kids from New
Hampshire would go to the University of
New Hampshire um
so I don't disagree with you at all
there and just to identify myself I'm
from Plymouth so um okay of course I'll
be concerned about you know no I I meant
the University of New Hampshire syst no
no no I but yeah I I fully support
supporting UNH and the other
universities so thank you you know it's
interesting I I think it was a
legislator when I was here a few years
ago said to me she said I understand
that my kids going to go away when she's
20 I just want her to come back when
she's 25 and I mean I think that's
another important thing to recognize is
that a lot of and this is true not just
in New Hampshire but in any part of the
United States young adults in their
early 20s are attracted to large urban
areas where there's a lot of excitement
energy when they reach another stage of
the life cycle when they're in their
late 20s and early 30s they start think
about the world differently and I think
part of that bump you see in those data
of old of people in their 30s and 40s
coming to Hampshire some of that is
return migration some of that's people
coming back so even if we can't hold on
to them in their early 20s it would be
good if the if they feel good about the
state and feel they can come back and
it's where they want to raise their
example other questions yes
representative Murphy thank you Mr
Speaker uh thank you Professor for
sharing this information with us um you
mentioned a lot of reasons um for people
coming to the state what are the reasons
that the migrants give for leaving yeah
the state that's a wonderful question
that I would dearly like an answer to
it's it's a very difficult question to
get an answer to because you have
to essentially know where they went so
that you can ask them the question so
the survey data that we use from New
Hampshire obviously it's for people who
are here if they've left we don't have
as much data on them so it's a I don't
have a clear answer to why they're
leaving I wish I did it's just it's
get yes represent
opal uh thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you Dr Johnson for this
um I do have a student at UNH so um
trying to do my best um I'm wondering if
in order to get the answer to uh
representative Murphy's question that
you'd like is it possible to use uh
voter registration data I mean if you're
moving out of state you're going to
change your registration to another
state and I'm wondering if um I know
there's a a national system that I think
Hampshire has withdrawn from but um I'm
wondering if that might be a source of
that the answer to that question of of
reaching out to contact those people as
they change their voter registration
yeah
um again it's a it's a d i mean we
sometimes we'll get you can get some
kind of the checkbox data I move for a
job or I move but to get into the data
the way we were able to talk to people
and actually get them to answer in their
own words it would it would would be a
wonderful thing to do I just I'll give
it some more thought but it's just it
would be very expensive to to do it
so representative wer think real estate
AG
[Music]
people true if they're of that age group
and they're they're have the resources
to buy or sell a house I mean when we're
talking about young adults in their
early 20s they're not going to likely
have
that but it's an I mean it's a good
idea and to that point represent wer we
do have uh tomorrow Bob Quinn from New
Hampshire Association of Realtors maybe
that's a good question to ask him
representative ORS thank you Mr chair uh
living in the bag Metropolis of Chai
Chester we're having a housing boom
which is more like a trickle but the
observation i' I've come up with is that
the people are moving back they've been
out of state they're moving back with
their children some of the children are
maybe some in school still some are just
out of school but that's what that's
area yeah I mean I I've heard I heard
from some of the school districts up
north early in the pandemic that all of
a sudden they had more kids in each
grade I mean like in a small school
district district 10 or 15 more kids is
a lot because it might mean a new
teacher uh and they were their big worry
was was this temporary was it just for
the next couple years or was it
permanent and so I think we're only
beginning to see now the answers to
those questions and it's it's a it's an
important
question
good all right uh thank you Dr Johnson
okay we are on our last uh but not least
presenter Rich labers from Deputy
Commissioner of the Department of
you see how I am the
Grade I do a left-handed layup I just
start um all right uh so thank you for
the opportunity to uh talk with the
members today uh so uh folks that
haven't um uh that I have not met before
Rich lers Deputy Commissioner with the
New Hampshire Department of Employment
Security and here with my uh trusted
colleague Brian gutb director of the
economic and labor market information
Bureau at the Department of Employment
Security and uh real quick before we get
into the the slides um uh we'll make
sure to uh make sure you guys have the
um electronic version as well um uh so
that um uh you have all the the colored
versions like we'll we'll be showing
today um and just a little bit about
what the department does and um the
focus of that is on uh Brian's Bureau
with the economic and labor market
information Bureau so uh Brian as an
economist leads a group of uh labor
market analysts and and economists um
that uh run that unit housed within
Employment Security so that's really
going to be what's uh largely on display
uh today during our presentation and the
work that they do um but the the
department also administers the state's
unemployment program both the collection
of Revenue and and the um distribution
of benefits to eligible individuals and
we also operate all of the state's New
Hampshire Works offices so the the
network of 12 American job Centers
located conveniently or we we think
conveniently for most folks uh
throughout the state uh where people can
go in um um receive assistance with
Reemployment efforts um or to get
questions answered with regard to
unemployment benefits um so with that
quick um recap of what the department is
all about I'll turn it over to Brian to
get us
started terrific Thank you Rich um
couple of things before I get into the
data um I want to make one thing very
clear some of the things that we'll talk
about today um we're going to talk about
the national economy because that really
sets the stage for what's going to
happen in the New Hampshire economy um
we'll also touch on some issues that are
pretty hot bed at the moment um and and
I really feel the need to say that we
don't address them from a political
perspective at all an ideological
perspective but we do address them
because they have the potential to
affect the labor force and if they
affect the labor force they have the
potential to affect employment I also uh
we'll talk a little bit about some of
the things that Professor Johnson talked
maybe with a little different focus and
if he's behind me um he may I'm going to
take a look just in case I say anything
that dramatically disagrees with him
Rich cover my back
please um just to go over uh and the
overall Outlook what we'll uh address in
in case very good chance I lose you u in
my comments um this forms our overall
Judgment of what's likely to happen uh
in 2005 one the US economy is performing
well um the probability of recession is
quite low in 2025 from our perspective
um the job losses nationally and in New
Hampshire are low and and exceptionally
low as Rich will mention um and point
out later in the presentation by
historical standards we're in a really
good position there um a key a real key
is that consumer spending nationally is
is strong wages have been rising faster
than inflation that means consumers uh
feel comfortable in spending and
continuing to spend with the low layoffs
and and Rising incomes um and I should
have put this in question mark
moderating inflation because it does
seem to have gotten a little bit
stickier and along with that hopefully
lower interest rates um that's kind of
the scenario for a positive 2025 Outlook
um importantly in New Hampshire we feel
like we're beginning 2025 with some
upward momentum and I'll show you why
come to that conclusion some uh
difficult things uh or some positive
other positive things um the June uh
since June New Hampshire's rate of
private sector job growth has actually
exceeded that of the US and um can't say
that um a lot over the last um year or
so um largely because of our labor force
constraints um big Improvement and one
of the reasons why our employment is
growing faster at the moment is we have
new businesses that have been starting
at a rate faster than than the nation
overall so a lot of entrepreneurial
activity a lot of new business starts
big issue ues problematic you heard some
of them from um Professor Johnson we'll
talk uh about them more from a labor
market perspective the demographics and
labor constraints that we face really
are the one significant challenge that I
see for our for our economic growth um
supporting movement into New Hampshire
is key to population and labor force
growth you heard that we'll show you
some slides um you know where we may
disagree a little bit is in terms of the
need to keep people people um every
rural state in the nation loses young
people for a period of time hopefully
they do come back it's very difficult to
keep those individuals um in their more
rural
States and housing shortages you'll hear
a lot about that you'll be dealing with
those issues they really are
exacerbating our demographic challenges
if we need to attract people um to grow
our labor force and ultimately our
employment then we have to have places
to house them and right now that is a
very significant challenge
so with that long
introduction um this is the key right
here to why this first chart why um we
feel positive about the direction of the
economy this chart shows two things
inflation which is the red line
obviously it spiked at over 9% it has
come down it was coming down pretty
rapidly it has eased in terms of
moderation more recently and actually up
ticked a little bit in the most recent
month the the green line is nationally
average wage growth year-over-year big
problem in that shaded area was
inflation Rising faster than wages when
that happens consumers are constrained
and a lot of not good things can happen
in the economy but for almost two years
now wage growth has
exceeded inflation and that means
consumers feel comfortable spending
um and it provides a significant lift uh
to the
economy that is shown in this chart
which is real cons real inflation
adjusted consumer expenditures
year-over-year through November so what
we see is that uh consumer expenditures
on a real basis above inflation are
holding up very well if that's occurring
consumer expenditures are 70% make up
70% of the nation's GDP it's very very
Trend another positive um and a and
somewhat of a reversal small businesses
which are really critical in New
Hampshire small businesses for much of
the past several years have shown
declining optimism and why would that be
in an economy that is ostensibly been
performing pretty well well you think
about
factors that have affected the national
economy over the last couple years
Rising wages as you saw and Rising
inflation and material prices goods and
material prices well small businesses
are affected most dramatically in those
circumstances bigger businesses have the
ability to accommodate they don't love
it but higher wages and they can
accommodate higher
material costs small businesses all
always take it on the chin in those
circumstances um the one aspect of this
chart is you see a big jump in optimism
and that's kind of traditional uh with a
republican Administration small
businesses generally feel more
optimistic I will tell you another re
why this is an important chart for me is
that I've tracked how this survey um
correlates with uh job growth in New
Hampshire and while it's not a obviously
a straight line correlation New
Hampshire has so many businesses it does
tend to track fairly well so um it it's
another reason to be optimistic about
job growth in New
Hampshire I mentioned that since uh June
or since the summer New Hampshire has
seen faster job growth year-over-year
private sector job growth which we focus
on I focus on um as a measure of what's
happening in the real economy um has
been growing faster than the nation um
overall some very positive upward
momentum ending the year after spending
much of the last couple of years just a
little bit slower solid still solid
employment growth but but now exceeding
the national rate of growth um one
survey that I have been paying attention
to relatively recently is done by the US
Census Bureau every two weeks and it
asks businesses in every state and this
reflects New Hampshire uh a number of
questions and one of the questions is
overall How would you describe this
business's C current performance either
excellent um above average or below
average poor or about the same and I
take a net of that respon those
responses for New Hampshire every two
weeks and average them over a month and
what you see is been an uptick you a
pretty positive more businesses are
positive about how their businesses are
performing and it has uptick about since
that time when we started seeing the
employment numbers exceed the national
so I do think there's a relationship
there again a reason to be optimistic
about 2025 I mentioned that the
entrepreneurial activity in the state um
this is new business formations it's
based on applications for employer
identification numbers and I take a
subset of those from among businesses
not who are not um sole Proprietors but
are businesses that are likely to have
employers manufacturers businesses
generally have employees and you see
taking the 2020 year as the base year
and seeing the percentage change in New
Hampshire always the red line and the
black line the us our rate of
entrepreneurial activity new business
formations has significantly exceeded
the national average and that generally
means there's going to be more highes
and I think we're seeing that reflected
now looking at how New Hampshire
compares to all other states 50 states
I'm sure this is a a little bit
difficult one without the colors but
this measures private sector job
growth from prior to the pandemic peak
in every state so Most states it was
February of 2020 some states it was a
little bit sooner New Hampshire it was
February of
2020 how many what percentage of private
sector jobs have we added since that
Peak prior Peak and what this chart
shows is that we're much better than our
neighbors in New England but beyond that
we're also much better than the
Northeast overall and why is that well
it's important for a number of reasons
shows how competitive we are in a region
that is difficult has had difficulty
competing nationally the states at the
far right that have seen the highest
rate of job growth are states that
generally didn't have the kind of
efforts to control the pandemic that
Northeastern states did Northeastern
states being more populous more densely
populated had to take measures uh more
severely in order to control uh the
pandemic and uh with that I'll let um
Deputy
La so with with the growth that you saw
in the prior chart from Brian nearly 5%
uh private sector job growth since the
peak prior to the pandemic obviously um
it has not been evenly experienced
across all sectors and so this slide you
can see uh the change in employment
since the first quarter of 2020 so this
is measured by looking at the uh
administrative uh reports that are filed
by employers each quarter uh so this is
really a gold standard of um of
reporting where these are actual numbers
as reported by employers and so here you
can see that the growth within the the
job growth with than the professional uh
scientific and Technical Services
industry so Professional Services um is
really um outpaced that of uh growth and
change in any other sector um from a uh
that 9, nearly 9,300 job gain it's about
a
24% increase compared to prior to the
pandemic um so it's a um well-paying
sector um you see you've got uh not only
your professional type services but you
have research and development uh you
have Consulting so a lot of growth uh
within the sector um in terms of the
number of jobs um the sector also as you
can imagine um from a from a
Professional Services standpoint it also
offers a lot of flexibility with regard
to uh scheduling flexibility location
flexibility with remote work opport
opportunities and as as we continue to
see that being a an important factor
particularly for younger workers uh that
have uh their ideas and demands about
work life balance uh that is an industry
that can really uh provide a lot to
those workers um and attract them to to
those types of jobs um a but a lot of
growth here within uh business services
and administrative support that's about
an 11 % gain um and uh construction um
about a
133% uh gain as you can see here um but
when we move to the bottom um of this
chart you can see those sectors that
have struggled to regain their pre
pandemic um employment numbers um so um
some government sectors here uh but some
important ones to note with our
hospitals um Hospital employment uh down
about 3% compared to where they were
prior to the pandemic um you can uh
compare that um against the Ambulatory
Care um sector both uh you know healthc
care employers Ambulatory Care providing
outpatient services um Ambulatory Care
um uh a growth of about 7% so uh compare
that with the the hospitals still being
3% down compared to where they were pre
prior to the pandemic um skilled nursing
so a long-term care Community uh they
are about even where they were prior to
the pandemic um and then at the bottom
of this chart local government and uh
retail uh both both down uh
significantly from where they were
question Mr
chairman is there a chance to ask a
question here do you mind questions in
the middle of your presentation uh
whenever people would like to ask them
all right go ahead representative thank
you Mr chairman and thank you uh
commissioner for taking this question I
look at manufacturing down here uh the
decrease
uh has tax rate adjustments downward
going to improve the manufacturing end
the companies that are basically in the
field of making things to ship come out
does the tax rate going down make a
difference in the number of uh employees
that they're
hiring um well Brian and I will both
take a stab at this one and all all of
those costs associated with cost of
production are going to are going to
have an impact it's about a
2% uh drop of that number represents
from where manufacturers were uh prior
to the prior to the pandemic um so I
think there there could be some good and
some bad with policy discussions um that
could be impacting those total costs as
they look um U into 2025 and
Beyond yeah I I mean costs are always
important um in terms of the issues that
are affecting manufacturing at the
moment um one thing that should be made
clear is that while we are seeing and we
haven't seen a lot of manufacturing
growth productivity in the manufacturing
sector has increased pretty
significantly um one that means for an
individual company they may be able to
do more with fewer people um but also
we're seeing a change overall in the
industry structure in manufacturing
going from less uh more labor intensive
uh manufacturers to less labor intensive
where more technology is being is
invested in the product than than labor
um and one of the issues that's
confronting manufacturers and this was
true during the pandemic is that they
have a hard time finding people one it's
an it tends to be an older Workforce or
it has been an older Workforce so a lot
of retirements over the last decade um
and will continue and you compound that
with changing Technologies which means
you know you have to train in a lot of
ways a new work a new Workforce um
because there's just new technologies
that there is an existing Workforce for
so a lot of factors long answer yeah and
that technology there is key uh but also
um thinking more U about that one of the
earlier comments too about some of the
flexibilities that some of the sectors
that have gained employment uh since
prior to the pandemic um difficult to
offer some of those flexibilities within
the manufacturing space uh so that that
can also be a difficult uh headwind for
them as more and more people um are
looking for opportunities that have that
um within their that uh job offer do we
know about the companies themselves
you're you're representing the number of
people lost how about are we losing
manufacturing companies or do we
know um we have those numbers and we can
uh provide that breakdown I think
manufacturing was about even uh from
where they were in terms of number of
establishments not a not a significant
change um is more likely to be on the
number per per manufacturer
than in actual exitus although that
varies to some degree by some Industries
some Industries just have harder time
competing in our state and tend to be uh
find other places in either the country
or around the world um where where
either likely costs are are
significantly more attractive and but it
varies
greatly so and this isn't necessarily
the this is a number of deploying units
that register with us about the same as
where they were first quarter of 2020 in
manufacturing okay um that's macro level
manufacturing there could be some change
within the the sub sectors within
manufacturing thank
you okay any other um and um oh go ahead
I think we're all set with questions
right
now um next slide looking at getting
into um some of the trends in
unemployment benefits what we see there
um this shows you the trend in new
claims activity so uh these are uh
people that are newly unemployed that
come in to file for unemployment um
these are uh the amount of claims the
volume of claims is below where we were
pre pandemic so still a historically low
volume of of of people coming in and
filing new claims we'll get into uh what
we're seeing on continued CL activity
just want to make a point why there's a
break in that time
series because if we put that that's the
pandemic and if we actually tried to
graph that all of the other lines would
have been flat on the bottom we were you
know
this we we were taking 20,000 claims a
week compared to 400 on a weekly basis
prior to the pandemic so it just it
would have blown this chart that's why
it's absent there another another reason
Brian didn't like the pandemic right
difficult um looking at the the
characteristics of the unemployed so
this is slightly different than uh the
people filing unemployment claims so
taken from the the monthly household
survey um which is what is used to then
determine uh total labor force and what
the state's unemployment rate is but you
can see here and how we've br broken out
the number of people that are
categorized as unemployed um that we we
break it into two groups of both good
and bad unemployment you know how can
there be good unemployment um well there
isn't from an unemployment claim
perspective but when you look at from a
labor force perspective you have
individuals represented here in the the
blue and the Shaded blue um and then in
the yellow uh what we would consider
good Unemployment uh where these are
people that are um that uh had not been
part of the labor force hadn't been
looking actively looking for employment
um and they're coming back in because of
feeling positive for one reason or
another so re-entrance into the labor
force um new entrance into the labor
force and then in yellow we have our our
voluntary job leav so if you're
voluntarily leaving unemployment that's
not a scenario that's going to uh gain
uh lead to eligibility for unemployment
benefits uh but it does indicate a level
of confidence and optimism in your
situation and in the economic situation
um in the labor market situation uh
where you're leaving voluntarily to seek
better employment um all in all um uh
about um
50% of of the breakdown from unemploy of
the unemployed um from the from the
house household survey would be in that
good category and then about a quarter
of that in the uh dark red here um which
are our permanent job uh losers so those
are folks that are are laid off and it's
not just a temporary laid off that's in
our our shaded red uh but the um about
25% would be in that uh bad situation of
a permanent job loss that hopefully then
we're working with in one of the New
Hampshire Works office offices to help
um I identify opportunities uh within
that same sector or identify training
opportunities to move into a new sector
uh but just looking at those
characteristics on both the good and the
bad within the um uh portion of the
labor force that's uh considered on uh
category okay thank representative Aly
yeah are those numbers
individuals uh those are in thousands so
in thousands so that's 28,000 there in
total sorry representative um on the um
within the new entrance re entance and
voluntary job levers that's about 13,000
so uh just under 50% of that total group
and then 7,000 in that dark red which is
the the bad unemployment the the
permanent job losers which is about
25% I I would also note that this was
from the third quarter which is the last
that we have the the solid data for and
the third quarter tends to have a
relatively higher number of temporary
layoffs because you have schools for for
one thing and traditionally that was a
time when manufacturing operations would
shut down for a short period of time um
a couple of weeks and if it happened to
fall during what is called the reference
week when this survey occurs so the
third quarter tends to have a relatively
higher number of temporary job losers
and just to show that uh we don't
cherry-pick the data um the quarters
prior to this were more um uh uh more in
the line of about 2third fitting within
that category of good unemployment being
your re-entrance new entrance voluntary
levers and about a third were in that
bad so um as Brian had indicate that
that third quarter had a little bit
shifted more a little bit towards uh bad
unemployment but the year overall still
still more in the line of about 2/3 in
category um and and talking before about
new claims for unemployment benefits as
as opposed to those that um are
identified in the household survey as
being in that unemployed group like you
saw in the last chart now we're looking
back at um unemployment claims so their
the weekly claims that individuals file
um as they continue to be
unemployed um what we're seeing and this
is um explains what you'll see with
regard to the unemployment compensation
trust fund but there has been a gradual
increase in duration um over the last
few years so here in this slide on the
left you can see the average duration at
the beginning of 2023 about 9.4 weeks
now remember folks are eligible for up
to 26 weeks they have to be able uh able
to work available for work actively
seeking work uh but they're eligible for
up to 26 weeks um what we've seen is a
is a gradual increase in that average
duration where the most recent numbers
for November put us set just under uh 12
weeks average duration so still less
than half of what is available to them
um but a two and a half week jump um
within that time period which um as you
would expect that leads to more benefits
being paid out of the trust
fund um and we you'll we Show a slide um
that how that impacts overall trust fund
performance and how that then correlates
with impacts on New Hampshire businesses
um so even though duration has uh been
gradually increasing the last few years
that 2 and 1/2 week jump over the last
two years um you can see here that
Hampshire still below where we were in
2019 so 2019 by all standards uh a
strong economy strong labor force
performance um low unemployment claim
activity in New Hampshire continues to
be below the levels experienced in
2019 so here New Hampshire just a little
over 1% below where we were in 19 when
we compare the same weeks back to those
same weeks in 19 however New Hampshire
is a little bit of an outlier in that
regard as you can see here both
Massachusetts and the blue line um the
nation as a whole and the black line are
both at about double digit percentage
increases um in terms of that weekly
unemployment claim activity so double
digit increases compared to where they
were prior to the pandemic uh so that's
something we we watch closely um and uh
to help put the current claim vol volume
in perspective but um so duration up
slightly but still overall below where
we were prior to the
pandemic how that then translates into
um
yes could I ask question yes on that's a
fairly
standard
uh slow rise but very
significant as it goes up uh uh for
duration representative for the duration
yeah do you think it's got do you have
an opinion as to whether it is um a
result of people being
pickier or are we facing more and more
people who just can't get jobs dropping
out um it it can it can be that it also
um can contribute to the um the pace at
which employers are hiring um as well
um we work with uh so these individ so
this these are individuals that are
utilizing the unemployment program so
they have required check-ins uh as
they're they're coming in and they're
working with counselors in their closest
office and trying to identify those
opportunities but I think it's it's
probably a little bit uh both depending
on the the situation but it could be a
uh probably more in line with a a a a
Slowdown in hiring uh during that period
as well compared to the um high level of
hiring that we saw uh coming out of the
pandemic but Brian do you have anything
to add to that uh no I think that that
rich is pretty accurate on that um there
is some element of businesses being a
little bit more cautious and you know we
saw until the last until this summer we
were seeing um a very slow decline in
the rate of private sector job growth
both nationally and in New Hampshire so
I do think there was a period of time
where certainly businesses in New
Hampshire were being more cautious in
their hiring and that may have led but I
think it's also a result of people
feeling as though there are more options
they are going to be a little bit more
choosy things like looking for remote
how many times I I've interviewed
candidates and you know they want all
remote work opportunities and chose not
to work for us so I think people are
being a little bit pickier and I think
businesses have been a little bit more
cautious
um and so on the um employer impact side
just from an an unemployment
compensation tax perspective um all of
those benefits are financed by employers
right with their their quarterly tax
payments um what employers are
experiencing right now are historically
low unemployment tax rates so here in
this chart you can see on the far right
um employers on average areay paying at.
61% employers pay that on the first
$114,000 in an in annual wages to each
employee that translates into about
$85 per employee per year a slight
increase over the uh prior quarter um
that translates into about an $8
increase uh for Employers in terms of
the change in those rates how this um uh
compares
regionally and nationally uh New
Hampshire employers have uh the lowest
unemployment tax burden in the uh
Northeast uh New Hampshire businesses
pay about onethird of the rate that
Massachusetts businesses pay to support
their unemployment program and then
nationally New Hampshire has the third
lowest unemployment tax burden uh the
two states that have a lower burden are
Florida um in Mississippi uh so not
states that we are generally uh
competing with but in the Northeast New
Hampshire is uh by far and way um the uh
has the lowest uh tax burden on
employers for their unemployment tax
payments not overall with everything but
within our wheelhouse and looking at the
um their unemployment tax burden and
it's that Revenue that is uh going into
our trust fund um one one uh uh change
that we are following closely Brian and
his team follow extremely closely with
their forecasting of the unemployment
compensation trust fund is with that uh
gradual increase in duration of the
length of an unemployment claim going up
about two and a half weeks over the last
two years um you do see here in this
slide that uh annualized benefit
payments are now just slightly exceeding
annual ized tax payments or the revenue
going into the trust fund so what that
means for employers um is that the the
trust fund is largely um absent any sort
of um uh economic downturn the the trust
fund is largely going to be in a very
tight window just below 400 million over
these next few years uh we ended 2024 at
about 393 million um compared that to
prior to the pandemic uh we are at 300
million uh so we are at historically
high levels for the trust fund um that
is uh largely um um attributed to low
claim levels over the last few years
increases in the number of employers and
businesses in the state that are paying
into that fund um but also um the the
trust fund was a beneficiary of some of
the unused uh cares act dollars uh to
the tune of about $109
million those uh dollars that had been
obligated out to an assortment of other
programs um were un unused in those
programs for whatever reason rather than
going back to Washington those dollars
uh waterfall into the unemployment fund
so now at a historically high level and
and more importantly we're at a solvent
level as measured uh by the federal
government uh when they rate all of the
and turn it over to
Brian so um one of the things that's
occurring is that um we had this chart
shows uh the job openings rate in the
state and the nation job openings rate
is a measure of the number of jobs that
businesses say they are looking for
workers divided by total employment in
the state and what we saw after the
pandemic because of people leaving the
labor force because of a lot of changing
of jobs churning people leaving in some
Industries for other industry a lot of
job openings that stayed High it has
been higher in New
Hampshire than the nation overall
largely because we have more labor
constraints but it has been coming down
and so we do see that and this is while
it looks troubling in some ways is a
positive because some of those job
openings are simply a reflection of
churning in the labor market people
going from one employer to another wages
were Rising people were jumping from one
employer to the other for a a wage
increase and that's very costly for
businesses um you know the need to train
new people Etc so while it looks
troubling it's still at a relatively
high level and so not especially
troubling from my
perspective I do have to stop Brian
there because
That was supposed to be my slide and I
looked at them incorrectly so I
apologize to Brian for that I can speak
topic um so getting back to how it was
supposed to go here with our run-of show
um looking within the demand uh with the
um demand that we've seen uh coming out
of the pandemic here it's at the um uh
industry level so you can see where the
the job posting Act ity has been what
type of employers so um largely within
the healthc care space um you see the
the top uh line numbers here um you've
got your traditional type of healthc
care employers with Physician Offices
hospitals uh with a fair amount of a job
posting activity um the next slide will
show you where those occupations are
that are in highest demand but you also
see your staffing agencies here as well
so uh the top line number number with
your employment placement agencies you
also have your temporary Help Services
agencies um and there uh been um a
strong uh on the demand side with a lot
of posting activity a lot of it within
the health care space um what we're told
from from employers within the healthc
care field that uh Reliance upon
staffing agencies and traveling nurses
which was a lot of how that was being uh
the the need for that
um that has been going in the other
direction from what we're hearing from
those employers but this is looking um
purely at the posting activity and so
what types of um Industries what type or
what the employers from each type of
Industry that are posting jobs um where
do they fall um when we look at it from
an occupational perspective you can see
registered nurses Head and Shoulders
above all of the other types of
occupations make sense healthc care is
our largest employment sector registered
nurses are the largest occupation within
that sector and continue to be the most
sought-after
position um across um all occupational
types and sectors in the state and then
we have quite a few other um healthcare
related occupations um that are all
highlighted here in red one point I
wanted to make about the register nurses
is that we um and it relates to the
prior slide um we saw a lot of temporary
help agencies at the top of the
industries well if you look individually
at the job postings you will see that
States from across the country are
advertising for nurses um in New
Hampshire they there is an effort to
grab employees not just in that industry
but in particular that industry almost
40% of those employment a agencies
temporary staff um occupations were in
healthc care occupations and 15 to 20%
are from other states so we're seeing a
lot of um competition for labor and that
is particularly true in registered
nurses how does if I may ask how does
the uh how does New Hampshire compare
because obviously that competition for
or or the number of registered nurses
needed is huge how does that compare
with other states or the US in general
it it it's a problem throughout the
country which is why um every state is
looking to Rob every other state of its
nurses it's why temporary help agencies
or employment agencies um are looking
for traveling nurses I can't tell you
how many I can't well I could how many
of those Registered Nursing job postings
were from uh America's nurses um and
it's just they are looking to recruit
nurses nurses and particularly younger
nurses who don't have family obligations
whatever and they'll travel for a month
to one location move to another location
so it's a nationwide problem and while
it's true in nursing you know the labor
market now is being separated from the
place of business more and more which
means our Engineers are being recruited
and can still live in New Hampshire but
work somewhere else um you know we see
postings from Microsoft we postings from
uh and allows people to continue to live
in New Hampshire and benefit yeah the
number of just the sheer number of
staffing agencies that are posting um
particularly for those healthc care jobs
those irn jobs compared to Prior of the
pandemic that just the number of them
exploded um in the in just a few short
years well one one of the things I've
heard too is that the nurses working for
staffing agencies can make so much more
they don't want to work for a regular
employer
and so that's exacer three times as much
the the advertised salaries were almost
three times what for a traveling nurse
what was advertised for a uh it's coming
down a little bit but it's still
significantly um greater and and cting
those registered nurses pretty
aggressively as well making it more
difficult for for our um our Healthcare
employers that need those positions
within the state I know this isn't in
your area but do you have any idea what
the university system is trying to
increase their nursing
program the well um I I know there have
been uh you know it's it's not a problem
that's been overlooked at all uh by the
both the community college system and
the university system and trying to
create more programs so that they can uh
attract more uh students and produce
more registered nurses um I know one
problem they continue to have is just
um getting enough uh individuals that
are qualified to be instructors in those
programs um and and attracting them away
from industry or um doubling down on
what they're already doing and and
trying to do courses after the their
regular shifts but what we've heard is
difficulty in getting those instructors
to lead more and more of those programs
another issue is the fact that we lose
about
1,00 nurses commute out of state every
day
um and largely to Massachusetts um U you
know the the Boston metro area is a
major medical um region um offers
significantly higher wages not so much
at entry level wage earners but as
nurses get more experience the wage
differentials become 30 $40,000 based on
our analysis of wage data um so we do
lose a lot there's only one region in
our state that attracts more nurses from
another state and that's Grafton County
because of Dartmouth Mary hitch
guot thank
you to
you all
right okay so let's look at some of the
challenges um one of the challenges we
face and that's uh a labor force the
size of our labor force this shows um
New Hampshire in the red line again
always in the red line um it indicates
that we are have a labor force that is a
bit smaller than it was prior to the
pandemic um I have a little bit of
skepticism of some of those numbers um
and it would appear to be inconsistent
with the job growth well it's not that
inconsistent when you think about H
what's happening around some of our
neighboring states one of the ways we
are able to grow our employment without
growing and I don't think this is a good
thing necessarily we're able to grow our
employment without growing our labor
force concomitantly is that we've been
attracting people to work in New
Hampshire who live in other states the
re the economies around us are not as
strong they're not adding as many
workers on a percentage basis those
people if they live in Maine or they
live in Vermont or even if they live in
Massachusetts and they work in New
Hampshire they're counted in the labor
force of those States so we don't get
the benefit of them counted in our labor
force but we may get the benefit of
their employment so that's one way we
can kind of make that inconsistent
inconsistency more
consistent um looking at um what I like
is what my favorite measure of um the
tightness of the labor force I'm not a
huge fan of the unemployment rate for a
number of reasons one of which is
unemployment is made up of so many
things Deputy mentioned all of the
different characteristics of the
unemployed it's not just people who lose
their jobs so it can be a little bit
misleading the number can rise if you
get a bunch of new people re-entering
the labor force or entering the labor
force this is my preferred measure it's
the employment to population ratio
people ages 25 to 54 participate in the
labor force at the highest rates of all
age groups 90% or so are in the labor
force when 85% of those in New Hampshire
have a job are
employed that I consider based on
historical data to be at full employment
so anytime we're above that we're really
in a very very tight labor market those
characteristics those times early end of
the 90s early
2000 contrast that with the Great
Recession we had excess labor for five
years it took us five years to get a
little bit beyond that actually to gain
back all the jobs we lost in the Great
Recession so labor shortages prior PRI
to the pandemic again pretty severe
labor shortages we were at 87% 88% um in
terms of employment to population ratio
it took us a while from the pandemic to
get back to that level but again we're
above the 85% level I will say the US
it's around 80% we have different
demographics but 85% so we're labor
constrained by this particular measure
and can have an impact on our ability
again
to grow our labor force but if we are
attracting from other states then that
allows us to some degree to overcome it
now I'll get into some of the things
that uh Professor Johnson mentioned this
a little bit different look looking at
the three Northern New England
states how does population grow I didn't
hear his entire presentation but they
grow natural population growth more
people being born than dying net
domestic migration more people moving
into your state than moving out and more
people moving internationally in than
are moving out this shows and I
apologize because it doesn't reflect the
fact that New Hampshire has had greater
population growth than than Maine but it
does reflect the individual numbers of
those three categories and there's two
things there's things that I really
wanted to highlight one of which is the
net domestic
migration Maine has done significantly
had significantly more domestic
migration then has New Hampshire is that
you know when I think about that I think
well Maine has about the same population
size population as New Hampshire it does
not have nearly as strong an economy and
it doesn't have nearly as vibrant
economy so to me that points to one
particular issue and that has housing
and their ability to accommodate housing
I'll talk a little bit more about that
but um a couple of other things New
Hampshire has um relied a lot on
international migration and I will say
that the characteristics of our
International migrants tend to be very
different than a lot of States we tend
to attract a number of Highly skilled
well-educated um International migrants
employed in some of our largest and most
important organizations um we also have
lower skilled and less well educated
migrants but on balance um our benefit
from international migration largely is
up Skilling our labor force Maine um not
as much Vermont is struggling for a lot
of reasons more people have been moving
out of that state except for a couple of
years during the pandemic um they have a
lot more labor challeng or demographic
challenges this is just a chart that
shows the net domestic migration over
the last 20 years um we did have a
period where we saw more people moving
out very consistent with that employment
growth that I showed you in the
population uh employment to population
ratio we had a hard time recovering our
jobs during that time period in addition
people who are moving into our state
tended to be as I characterize them two
wag ear or married couple families
likely both college educated with
children during the Great Recession they
probably owned a house somewhere else
very likely they were underwater based
on what happened to housing values they
would have wanted to sell that house to
move to New Hampshire and they would
have wanted to buy a house in that was
difficult with credit conditions so that
contrib we bounced back some but we you
know we had a great increase during the
pandemic as did all Northern New England
states saw a benefit during that time
period as people look to uh Escape more
densely populated areas um Professor
Johnson mentioned some of the rural
school school districts well if you
looked and I did look at things like
searches for houses in different
counties some of the biggest increases
were in places like Carol County Grafton
County saw a huge increase and it was a
result of the pandemic and people
looking for for more open space and less
um congestion net international
migration has been very strong you see
near the end n 2019 to 2020 well that
was a pandemic you know very difficult
to move anywhere you couldn't fly you
know you could it was difficult to
travel so that that but if you kind of
even that out as Rich likes to say point
that out and smooth it it's pretty
consistent um with the prior years prior
to the pandemic but still important
source of of um our employment and labor
force growth and that's shown in this
chart um immigrants in New Hampshire
have a higher labor force participation
rate um than native born uh population
and and a higher employment rate um
overall and again a lot of this has to
do with the fact that our international
migration tends to be higher skilled
they tend to have higher levels of
educational attainment I have some
slides on that that I didn't include
here um a lot of people with graduate
degrees a lot of college educated um
individuals where are they employed and
this is important um looking at Key
Industries manufacturing being one of
them professional Tech technical science
Technical Services so they're employed
in a lot of Industries but manufacturing
and professional scientific and
Technical Services employ an awful lot
of um uh foreign born workers and I
highlighted construction there because
I'm very skeptical of this number um I'm
skeptical because that particular
industry tends to employ if you're
looking for undocumented immigrants and
undocumented migration you'll see a lot
of that in the construction industry so
this is based on um Census Bureau survey
and undocumented um individuals
generally don't respond to government
surveys
so almost done um but I mentioned the um
difference between Maine and New
Hampshire in terms of migration domestic
migration and I think this plays a role
looking at new housing units authorized
by building permit this is um annualized
so it's a 12-month rolling sum you see
you know a little about 10 years ago you
started to see a real Divergence in
terms of the number of homes that were
permitted in main versus New Hampshire
um and so I think that has U basically
Maine has accommodated more growth um
and has to to be honest with you saw
that they also had you know a net
negative natural population growth uh uh
of 25,000 or more where New Hampshire's
was a little more modest Although our is
going to increase um so they have to
accommodate uh we will have to
accommodate movement into the state if
we want our population and ultimately
grow um just shows net state-to-state
migration I I didn't update it to 2024
but as a percentage of 2020
population um you know this three-year
time period New Hampshire all of the
Northern New England states and did very
well Maine did especially well people
moving to that state um and again during
the pandemic and post pandemic we saw uh
people looking to exit from more densely
populated areas Northern New England
neighboring very densely populated
regions in the Northeast we were the
beneficiaries of that even Vermont which
for 10 years prior had seen out
migration net out migration um just
you'll hear about this tomorrow so I
won't spend time the number of houses
for sale is down you know um
dramatically um from pre-pandemic
levels the housing vacancy rate
according to the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority is well below what you
would expect or what you would like to
see around 5% it varies by by reasons um
and by communities but still very low
again if we're going to rely on people
moving into the state we have to be able
to accommodate them and that is the way
we are going to grow we have the among
the lowest birth rates although I will
say the most recent year we saw an
increase in our in our birth rates we're
no we were no longer number one or two
lowest birth rates we I think dropped to
number five or six
lowest um lastly or next to lastly um
our forecast and I'm you know went back
and looked at what I said last year or
yeah or yeah was last year or two years
ago last year two years ago whatever
ever I've consistently under forecast a
little bit um this year um I'm not going
to make that mistake again um I hope um
but I will say I did never forecast a
recession so I was one of the few people
who didn't think we were going to have a
recession in 2023 but this is different
in that I do expect um that New
Hampshire will see modestly improved
um uh job job growth compared to the US
and that's a trend from a change from
the last few years
lastly and this is where you know
politically um looking at um you know
dodging bullets this is not a political
statement but these are some of the
threats looking from Strictly an
economic perspective um higher tariffs
run the risk of raising inflation uh
increasing prices um and one of the
problems with tariffs that doesn't get
mentioned very often um yes it does
raise um imported goods prices relative
to products services that are
produced internally in in our country
but it is also a license for us
producers to raise their prices and I
tell you that does happen so they are
they are given more freedom to raise
their prices so overall price levels do
Rise um reducing immigration could
tighten already limited labor Supply um
and
reinflation could rekindle and I we're
already seeing interest rates not
dropping and the FED is saying saying
that it might not drop rates as much or
as fast as it thought it would um and
the rest of these things I the only
thing I I would not note is oil price
spikes which you know for 50 years every
recession had an oil price spike
component to it um we have weathered
some pretty difficult things in the in
the market for in the oil Market um
largely because we have we're producing
more now than we ever did in this
country and we're actually exporting um
we're we're exporting or o um so I think
we can handle some International crisis
not dramatically but we can handle that
a little bit better so with that we'll
stop and take questions and I'll just
point out there is a lot that um made uh
got cut on the editing floor here from
the presentation so if there are are
topics that are addressed here that
people would like to see further
explored uh we can do that please ask um
and if there are other topics that
didn't get addressed if there is data
that we have we'd be more than happy to
provide it so please ask on that as
well great thank you uh Senator
question
14es of
25 notjoin the
workforce
post and question what is that number
and second part is what percentage of
regained um so what we can do Senator is
we can uh provide an
updated uh slide I believe what you what
we showed before was uh participation
broken down it was a pre- pandemic
versus where we were that point
participation rates by age cohort and
and by gender as well so we can provide
that on the child care question um so we
know from an occupation uh perspective
on uh licensed facilities but it's the
unlicensed that uh we don't capture but
we also we have data there on the on the
um uh employees within the licensed
facilities that we could provide yep
thank you thank
questions great seeing none thank you
you okay with that that concludes
uh today's list of presentations uh yeah
we'll reconvene tomorrow at 9:00 um we
have have a slate of presenters again I
expect the time frame to be about the
same 9 to 3 roughly and then um next
week as I told you uh Reserve um Tuesday
and Wednesday I think that's the 21st
and the 22nd I believe um I don't have
an agenda for that yet but um th I I
anticipate those meetings will start at
10: 10: a.m. this 9:00 am. was just to
accommodate uh all the presentations but
I yeah t u Tuesday and Wednesday next
week will be 10: am any questions or we
all